This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When Leon Fleischer was a small child, his older brother took piano lessons. The brother didn't much care for them. But afterwards, little Leon would climb onto the piano bench and play, note for note, the pieces his brother had practiced. That's when his mother realized Leon was the one who should study the instrument. Leon Fleischer made his debut at Carnegie Hall in 1944. He was just 16 years old. Who is to perform Brahms piano concerto number one in D minor. A New York Times music critic said this performance established him as one of the most remarkably
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当莱昂·弗莱舍还是个小孩子时，他的哥哥在学钢琴。哥哥对钢琴课并不怎么感兴趣。但课后，小莱昂会爬上琴凳，把哥哥练习过的曲子一个音符不差地弹出来。就在那时，他的母亲意识到莱昂才是那个应该学习这门乐器的人。莱昂·弗莱舍于1944年在卡内基音乐厅首次登台演出。当时他年仅16岁。他要演奏勃拉姆斯的D小调第一钢琴协奏曲。《纽约时报》的一位音乐评论家称，这场演出确立了他作为
gifted of the younger generation of American keyboard artists. He went on to perform with the world's top orchestras throughout the 1950s and early 60s. Paul's story here and Leon Fleischer's life is a triumph. But then something unexpected happened. He started to notice an odd stiffness in his right index finger. His fourth and fifth finger started curling under. The pain and stiffness grew steadily worse. Within a matter of months, his career as a concert pianist was virtually over. As you can well imagine without becoming melodramatic,
美国年轻一代键盘艺术家中最杰出天才之一的地位。在整个20世纪50年代和60年代初，他继续与世界顶级管弦乐团合作演出。保罗在这里讲述的故事，以及莱昂·弗莱舍的人生，是一场胜利。但随后发生了一些意想不到的事情。他开始注意到右手食指有一种奇怪的僵硬感。他的第四根和第五根手指开始向内蜷缩。疼痛和僵硬感持续加重。在短短几个月内，他作为音乐会钢琴家的职业生涯几乎结束了。正如你可以想象的那样，如果不夸大其词，
it was... I was in a very despairing state of depression for about two years. If we were to take stock of Leon Fleischer's life at this point, we might say it was a tragedy. But Leon Fleischer still had so much music in him, so he reinvented himself, becoming a much admired conductor and teacher. Meanwhile, he continued to try every available measure to heal his right hand. Eventually, a combination of Botox injections and deep tissue massage started to help. In 2003, Leon Fleischer made a triumphant return to Carnegie Hall.
那是……我在大约两年的时间里处于一种非常绝望的抑郁状态。如果我们要在此时盘点莱昂·弗莱舍的人生，我们可能会说这是一场悲剧。但莱昂·弗莱舍心中依然有太多的音乐，所以他重塑了自己，成为了一位备受推崇的指挥家和教师。与此同时，他继续尝试一切可行的办法来治愈他的右手。最终，肉毒杆菌注射和深层组织按摩的结合开始产生效果。2003年，莱昂·弗莱舍在卡内基音乐厅实现了凯旋回归。
He was 75 years old. The next year, he released a CD, his first two-handed recording in more than 40 years. Today we conclude this year's U2.0 series on Purpose, Passion, and Meaning. We'll bring you a favorite episode about the stories we tell about ourselves, and the many subtle and powerful ways in which our personal narratives shape who we are. How the way we understand the ups and downs of our lives can shape the ups and downs of our lives, this week on Hidden Brain. As we make our way through life, it can feel as if we are buffeted by a swiftly moving
当时他75岁。第二年，他发行了一张CD，这是他40多年来首次录制的双手演奏唱片。今天，我们结束本年度关于“目标、激情与意义”的U2.0系列节目。我们将为您带来一期关于我们讲述自身故事的精彩剧集，以及个人叙事以多种微妙而强大的方式塑造我们自我的方式。我们如何理解人生的起伏，又如何塑造人生的起伏，本周《隐藏的大脑》为您呈现。当我们走过人生旅程时，感觉就像被一阵阵快速移动的
series of events. Sometimes it's all we can do to keep our heads above water as we wait for the next wave to crash over us. But research in psychology hints at a different process unfolding beneath the waves, an undercurrent that has powerful effects on our well-being, mental health, and life outcomes. powerful effects on our well-being, mental health, and life outcomes. At Olin College, psychologist Jonathan Adler studies how our minds are shaped by this undercurrent and how becoming mindful of it can help us better deal with setbacks and failure. Jonathan Adler, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, I'm so excited to be here with you. Jonathan, I want to take you back to your college days in Maine. You were a capable and hardworking student,
事件所冲击。有时，我们竭尽全力才能保持头部露出水面，等待下一波浪潮拍打在我们身上。但心理学研究暗示，在波浪之下正发生着一个不同的过程，一股对我们的幸福感、心理健康和人生结果有着强大影响的暗流。对我们的幸福感、心理健康和人生结果有着强大影响。在欧林工程学院，心理学家乔纳森·阿德勒研究了我们的思想是如何被这股暗流所塑造的，以及意识到这一点如何能帮助我们更好地应对挫折和失败。乔纳森·阿德勒，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。哦，我很高兴能和你在一起。乔纳森，我想带你回到你在缅因州的大学时代。你是一个能干且勤奋的学生，
but you were also struggling with a secret. What were you going through? Yeah, like you said, I was a good student. I was curious and took classes in a ton of different departments. But socially, I was more reserved. I had a really tight group of friends in high school. And I was sort of angry that that chapter of my life had closed just because high school had ended.
但你也正与一个秘密作斗争。你当时经历了什么？是的，就像你说的，我是一个好学生。我很好奇，选修了许多不同院系的课程。但在社交方面，我比较内向。我在高中时有一个非常亲密的朋友圈。而我当时有点生气，因为仅仅因为高中结束了，我人生中的那个篇章就关闭了。
And I was also struggling with my sexuality, though that's not something I was necessarily conscious of for a big chunk of college. So you came up with a solution to these challenges and it was something of a radical solution. What did you, what was the plan you devised? Yeah, well so a lot of college, a lot of students at the college spent part of their junior year studying abroad and that seemed to me like a rare opportunity to take a break from my regular life and figure out some things about myself. So I ended up in Perth,
而且我也在为自己的性取向而挣扎，尽管这并不是我在大学很大一部分时间里必然意识到的事情。所以你为这些挑战想出了一个解决方案，而且这是一个相当激进的方案。你当时设计了什么计划？是的，嗯，大学里很多学生在大三时会去国外留学，这对我来说似乎是一个难得的机会，可以从我的常规生活中抽离出来，弄清楚关于我自己的事情。所以我最终去了珀斯，
which is on the West Coast of Australia. Wow. Which is literally as far away from my life as you could get. I mean, if you draw a line from New England through the center of the earth, you end up off the coast of Perth. And this was your way of reinventing yourself. Well, it felt like an opportunity to step outside my life and sort of explore who I was in a context
它位于澳大利亚西海岸。哇。这在字面上是我能离我的生活最远的地方。我的意思是，如果你从新英格兰穿过地心画一条线，你最终会到达珀斯海岸附近。这就是你重塑自我的方式。嗯，这感觉像是一个走出我生活，去探索我在一个环境中究竟是谁的机会，
that wouldn't then have any ramifications for the life that I was living. So, okay, so you fly all the way to Australia. What happens? Did you find that your social life improved, that you found deep connections with other people? No. When I arrived, I knew that I was going to need to find some friends. So I auditioned for the theater department's play. I was studying psychology and theater in college, and I knew
那个环境随后不会对我正在过的生活产生任何影响。好吧，所以你一路飞到澳大利亚。发生了什么？你发现你的社交生活改善了吗，你与其他人建立了深厚的联系吗？没有。当我到达时，我知道我需要找一些朋友。所以我参加了戏剧系的试镜。我在大学里学习心理学和戏剧，我知道
that being involved in a show was a surefire way to make fast friends and that it also was a place where there might be opportunities to date. And so the play that the department was doing that semester was this weird, postmodern adaptation of Chekhov's classic Uncle Vanya by the admittedly brilliant British playwright Howard Barker. And there's this relatively minor character in the original play, Asterov, who's this brooding intellectual who just thinks but never does anything.
参与演出是结交新朋友的稳妥方式，而且那也是一个可能有机会约会的地方。所以那个学期系里排演的剧目是英国剧作家霍华德·巴克改编的契诃夫经典剧作《万尼亚舅舅》，这是一个奇怪的后现代版本，这位剧作家确实才华横溢。在原剧中有一个相对次要的角色，阿斯特罗夫，他是一个沉思的知识分子，只会思考却从不采取行动。
And I figured, oh, that's perfect for me. But much to my astonishment, I got cast as Vanya, which is one of the only leading roles that I'd ever had. Wow. Yeah, so most of Chekhov's plays are about people who are stuck in their lives and sort of consumed with what might have been the joke about Chekhov is that nothing ever happens. And so this playwright, Barker, took this play and decided to imagine what would happen
我想，哦，那对我来说太完美了。但令我大吃一惊的是，我被选为万尼亚，这是我演过的仅有的几个主角之一。哇。是的，所以契诃夫的大多数剧作都是关于那些被困在生活中，沉溺于“如果当初怎样”的人，关于契诃夫的笑话是“什么事都没发生”。所以这位剧作家巴克拿走了这个剧本，决定想象一下如果发生什么会怎样，
if the same characters just did whatever their impulses told them to do. So in this version, there are gun battles and unconstrained sex and a whole lot of chaos. It's total liberation. And I was an anxious actor, and so having to carry this play in a role that was deeply unsuited to my natural tendencies was all consuming. I had gone looking for the kind of liberation that these characters were given by their playwright,
如果同样的角色只是按照他们的冲动行事。所以在这个版本中，有枪战、不受约束的性行为和大量的混乱。这是一种彻底的解放。我是一个焦虑的演员，所以必须在一个与我的天性完全不符的角色中支撑起这部戏，这让我精疲力竭。我曾去寻找那种剧作家赋予这些角色的解放，
but in finding it in this fictional world, it completely shut down my own world. I felt I had to spend my time mastering this incredibly complex and unnatural language. I mean, the first line of the play is just the word uncle repeated over and over. And I just lost all the bandwidth for everything else. It ended up being one of the loneliest periods of my life with me actually starting to count down the days until I could come home.
但在虚构的世界中找到它，却彻底关闭了我自己的世界。我觉得我必须花时间掌握这种极其复杂且不自然的语言。我的意思是，剧本的第一句台词就是“舅舅”这个词被反复重复。我失去了处理其他所有事情的带宽。这最终成为我一生中最孤独的时期之一，我甚至开始倒计时，直到我可以回家。
And what I had envisioned as a time for freedom and exploration actually became this burdened, lonely time. And I think it set me back in the process of coming out. and I think it set me back in the process of coming out. So you returned to Maine after the semester abroad. You're back now in the same college where you were previously frustrated. What goes through your head at this point? I think I felt profoundly disappointed in myself for not having capitalized on this rare opportunity and stifled to be back in my old life without having figured anything out. And yeah, so I think I just sort of put my head down and kept doing what I knew how to
而我所设想的自由和探索的时光，实际上变成了一段沉重、孤独的时光。我认为这让我在出柜的过程中倒退了。我认为这让我在出柜的过程中倒退了。所以你在海外学期结束后回到了缅因州。你现在回到了之前让你感到沮丧的同一所大学。此时你脑子里在想什么？我想我对自己感到深深的失望，因为没有利用好这个难得的机会，回到旧生活中却什么也没弄清楚，这让我感到窒息。是的，所以我想我只是低下头，继续做我所知道的
do, which was be a brain, not a fully integrated body. Jonathan's time in Australia felt like more than a misadventure. It felt like a sign. He had made the trip with high hopes, hoping to become a new person. When he returned no different than before, it didn't just feel the same. It felt worse.
事情，那就是做一个大脑，而不是一个完全整合的身体。乔纳森在澳大利亚的时光感觉不仅仅是一次不幸的冒险。这感觉像是一个信号。他怀着崇高的期望踏上了旅程，希望成为一个新人。当他回来时，却与以前毫无两样，这不仅感觉一样，甚至感觉更糟。
Many of us have had experiences similar to Jonathan's. We suffer setbacks and failures, humiliations and disappointments. When these happen to us frequently enough, we start to think that we will never be happy, never be whole. When we come back, why unhappiness can breed unhappiness and how to break the cycle. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Jonathan Adler spent much of his young adulthood feeling unsatisfied, yearning for more.
我们许多人都经历过与乔纳森类似的遭遇。我们遭受挫折和失败，屈辱和失望。当这些事情频繁发生在我们身上时，我们开始认为自己永远不会快乐，永远不会完整。当我们回来时，为什么不快乐会滋生不快乐，以及如何打破这个循环。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。乔纳森·阿德勒在年轻时的大部分时间里都感到不满足，渴望更多。
He sensed he was gay, but didn't feel comfortable coming out. He spent a semester in Australia to break free of the constraints of his college life in Maine, but found that he was just as lonely on another continent. Sometime after he returned to the United States, however, Jonathan made a discovery. He came by the work of a pioneering scientist in a field known as narrative psychology. Dan McAdams at Northwestern University was arguing that the stories we tell about our lives have
他感觉到自己是同性恋，但对出柜感到不自在。他在澳大利亚度过了一个学期，试图摆脱缅因州大学生活的束缚，却发现自己在另一个大陆上同样孤独。然而，在他回到美国后不久，乔纳森有了一个发现。他接触到了一位先驱科学家的工作，该领域被称为叙事心理学。西北大学的丹·麦克亚当斯一直在论证，我们讲述的关于我们生活的故事对我们的
profound effects on our well-being. Jonathan moved to Northwestern, became Dan's PhD student and later his scientific collaborator. In time, Jonathan came to see his own life through the lens of his research. He realized that he had been telling the story of his life in a way that was self-defeating. And he came to see that by telling that story differently, it could make a profound difference. We'll get to that in a moment. First, I asked Jonathan to explain to me the basic idea behind narrative psychology. You can't totally control the things that happen to you in your life.
幸福感有着深远的影响。乔纳森搬到了西北大学，成为了丹的博士生，后来成为了他的科学合作者。随着时间的推移，乔纳森开始通过他研究的视角来看待自己的人生。他意识到，他一直以一种自我挫败的方式讲述自己的人生故事。他开始明白，通过以不同的方式讲述那个故事，可以产生深远的影响。我们稍后会谈到这一点。首先，我请乔纳森向我解释叙事心理学背后的基本理念。你无法完全控制生活中发生在你身上的事情。
You have some more say about how you make sense of it. And it's important to remember, we're talking about stories here. So we know from research on memory that we're not very good at recording the objective facts of our experience For a long time that frustrated cognitive scientists, but in more recent years It's become clear that our memory works like this for a good reason So if you think about why we have memory in the first place
你对如何理解这些事情有更多的发言权。记住，我们在这里谈论的是故事，这一点很重要。所以我们从记忆研究中知道，我们并不擅长记录我们经历的客观事实。长期以来，这让认知科学家感到沮丧，但在最近几年，很明显，我们的记忆之所以这样运作是有充分理由的。所以如果你思考一下为什么我们首先会有记忆，
It's not so we can hold on to every single thing that's happened to us in some veridical way we have memories so that we can make sense of what's happening to us right now and anticipate what might happen next. So if you walk by a cave and a bear jumps out, you don't necessarily need to remember that cave and that bear, but you need to remember that dangerous things might hide in dark places. So the slippery, reconstructive nature of memory is a feature of the system. It's not a bug. And stories are an amazing tool for holding on to the meaning of our past experiences. So the objective
那不是为了让我们能以某种真实的方式保留发生在我们身上的每一件事，我们拥有记忆是为了让我们能理解现在正在发生的事情，并预测接下来可能会发生什么。所以如果你走过一个洞穴，一只熊跳了出来，你不一定需要记住那个洞穴和那只熊，但你需要记住危险的东西可能隐藏在黑暗的地方。所以记忆那种滑动的、重构的本质是系统的特征，而不是漏洞。而故事是保留我们过去经历意义的绝佳工具。所以客观
facts of our lives are what they are, but the stories are about where we draw connections between things, where we parse the chapter breaks of our lives. And those are narrative acts, not historical acts. And the way we do that can have big implications for our well-being. Jonathan and Dan McAdams have found that one of the most crucial choices we make in telling our stories, and it's important to underscore that most of us make these choices unconsciously, is where we start and stop the different chapters of our life story. All lives have good and bad in it and so stories that start bad and end bad
事实就是那样，但故事是关于我们在事物之间建立联系的地方，我们在哪里解析人生的章节断点。这些是叙事行为，而不是历史行为。我们这样做的方式会对我们的幸福感产生重大影响。乔纳森和丹·麦克亚当斯发现，我们在讲述故事时做出的最关键的选择之一——重要的是要强调我们大多数人是在无意识中做出这些选择的——就是我们在哪里开始和结束人生故事的不同章节。所有的人生都有好有坏，所以那些以坏开始、以坏结束的故事
don't feel great and stories that start good and end bad don't feel great. And stories that start good and end good, those feel good. But what we find in the research is that where we draw connections between the negative and the positive matters a lot. So stories that we narrate as starting bad and ending good, we call that a redemption sequence. And stories that start good and end bad, we call that a contamination sequence.
感觉并不好，而那些以好开始、以坏结束的故事感觉也不好。那些以好开始、以好结束的故事，感觉很好。但我们在研究中发现，我们在负面和正面之间建立联系的地方非常重要。所以那些我们叙述为以坏开始、以好结束的故事，我们称之为“救赎序列”。而那些以好开始、以坏结束的故事，我们称之为“污染序列”。
I see, so a redemption sequence is in some ways something bad happens to you, but in some ways you're rising from the ashes, so redemption. And a contamination sequence is things are going pretty well, but then something bad happens to you, and then everything is downhill from there. So one basically has an upward trajectory, the other one has a downward trajectory.
我明白了，所以救赎序列在某种程度上是坏事发生在你身上，但在某种程度上你从灰烬中崛起，所以是救赎。而污染序列是事情进展得相当顺利，但随后坏事发生在你身上，然后一切都走下坡路了。所以一个基本上有向上的轨迹，另一个有向下的轨迹。
That's right, and again, we're remembering these are stories. So this is how we narrate the experience, not necessarily the objective facts of our lives, because all lives have good and bad. I mean, your story about going to Australia, for example, you know, you go to Australia with high hopes, you get the starring role in a play. We know many people would say that's a very good thing to have happened to you. And then the play turns out to not be quite what was best for you, or the role turns out to be not what was best for you, and you end up being very lonely. And then you can sort of see a downward sort of
没错，再次提醒，我们要记住这些是故事。所以这是我们叙述经历的方式，而不一定是人生的客观事实，因为所有的人生都有好有坏。我的意思是，以你去澳大利亚的故事为例，你知道，你怀着崇高的期望去澳大利亚，你在戏里得到了主角。我们知道许多人会说那是一件发生在你身上的非常好的事情。然后那部戏结果并不完全是你最好的选择，或者那个角色结果并不是你最好的选择，你最终变得非常孤独。然后你可以看到某种向下的
spiral in some ways, and in some ways, it becomes a contamination story, a story where something good turned bad, and then you come back to the United States. And now it feels like the bad thing that happened in Australia is with you even now. And that's sort of how contamination works. It has a contagious effect and spreads and infects other things.
螺旋，在某种程度上，它变成了一个污染故事，一个好事变坏事的故事，然后你回到了美国。现在感觉在澳大利亚发生的坏事即使在现在也伴随着你。这就是污染运作的方式。它具有传染性，会扩散并感染其他事物。
That's right. And again, I didn't know about Dan's work at that moment in my life. So I wasn't thinking about it in storied terms, but indeed, I think I was living out what I can now retrospectively see was a contamination sequence. I wanna talk a little bit about the effects
没错。而且我当时并不知道丹的研究。所以我并没有从故事的角度去思考，但确实，我想我正在经历我现在回顾时可以看到的“污染序列”。我想谈谈这些序列对我们生活的影响，
of these sequences on our life, the effect of a redemption narrative and a contamination narrative. What effects do these different stories have on our lives? What's the difference on our mental well-being and happiness of redemption stories versus contamination stories? I have a nice short example of this
救赎叙事和污染叙事的影响。这些不同的故事对我们的生活有什么影响？救赎故事与污染故事在心理健康和幸福感上有什么区别？我有一个很好的简短例子，
from a participant in one of my earliest studies, briefly. This was a little middle-aged man he's recounting the story of the first date that he went on with the woman that he ultimately goes on to marry and The facts of the story are they go out when he brings her home They're standing on her front porch and he leans in for a kiss and then her dad opens the front door and interrupts them So in the version that this man narrated when he shared his life story as part of participating in our research, he frames the experience as a redemption sequence. He says, it really brought us close right at the very start of our relationship and we stayed that way ever since. So this
来自我早期研究的一位参与者，简而言之。这是一个中年男人，他正在讲述他与最终结婚的那个女人第一次约会的故事。故事的事实是他们出去了，当他送她回家时，他们站在她的前廊上，他凑过去想亲吻她，然后她的父亲打开前门打断了他们。在这个男人作为我们研究参与者分享他的人生故事时所叙述的版本中，他将这段经历构建为一个救赎序列。他说，这在我们的关系刚开始时确实让我们变得亲密，从那以后我们就一直保持着这种状态。所以这个
embarrassing moment had given them something to laugh about on their second date and and maybe it accelerated their connection. But he might have narrated the exact same sequence of events by concluding that it was this stain on the beginning of their relationship that could have contaminated the relationship in a way that they moved on from but never could erase. So neither version is more accurate in the historical sense. These are narrative interpretations that take on different thematic arcs, redemption and contamination.
尴尬的时刻让他们在第二次约会时有了可以拿来开玩笑的事情，也许这加速了他们的联系。但他本可以叙述完全相同的事件序列，结论是这是他们关系开始时的污点，可能会以一种他们虽然走出来了但永远无法抹去的方式污染了这段关系。所以没有哪个版本在历史意义上更准确。这些是采取不同主题弧线的叙事解释，救赎和污染。
But these different ways of narrating our lives have different implications for your well-being. We find over and over that when redemption sequences occur in people's life stories, they tend to be associated with positive well-being, good life satisfaction, lower levels of things like depression, higher self-esteem, and it's just the opposite for themes of contamination.
但这些叙述我们生活方式的不同方式对你的幸福感有不同的影响。我们反复发现，当救赎序列出现在人们的人生故事中时，它们往往与积极的幸福感、良好的生活满意度、较低的抑郁水平、较高的自尊相关联，而污染主题则恰恰相反。
So what's important here, and you've mentioned this before, is that the underlying facts of the story don't have to change for the story, in fact, to be a very different kind of story. So, for example, in your own life, you're still a gay man coming of age at a time when homophobia is rampant, you're still lonely in college,
所以这里重要的是，你之前也提到过，故事背后的事实不需要改变，故事本身实际上可能是一个非常不同的故事。例如，在你自己的生活中，你仍然是一个在恐同现象猖獗时期成长的同性恋男人，你在大学里仍然很孤独，
the Australia trip was less of an escape and more of a setback, but you can tell both a contamination story as well as a redemption story built around those facts. That's right, and again, the shift there is about where we draw the chapter breaks in my life. So if we end that story, end that chapter, when I get back to college, it feels like a contamination sequence.
澳大利亚之行与其说是逃避，不如说是一次挫折，但你可以围绕这些事实讲述一个污染故事，也可以讲述一个救赎故事。没错，再次强调，这里的转变在于我们在人生中画章节断点的地方。所以如果我们结束那个故事，结束那个章节，当我回到大学时，它感觉就像一个污染序列。
But if I string it together with the things that came next, spoiler alert, it feels like a redemption sequence. Tell me what happened next and how it becomes a redemption story. As I neared the end of college, I largely dealt with my internal turmoil by just throwing myself into my work. So I was one of the top students in my class and I got some awards and I took a research job after college at Harvard, which was, you know, my plan was going to graduate school. And I felt like I had done everything expected of me.
但如果我把它和接下来发生的事情串联起来，剧透预警，它感觉就像一个救赎序列。告诉我接下来发生了什么，以及它是如何变成一个救赎故事的。当我的大学生活接近尾声时，我主要通过全身心投入工作来处理内心的动荡。所以我当时是班里最顶尖的学生之一，我获得了一些奖项，大学毕业后我在哈佛找到了一份研究工作，你知道，我的计划是去读研究生。我觉得我已经完成了别人对我期望的一切。
And I didn't really seek out any mentorship as I applied to 10 very competitive PhD programs. And then when the whole process was done, I only got into one program. So I always tell students, you only go to one school. So it only takes one. And that is true. But at the time it felt like a shock.
而且我在申请10个竞争非常激烈的博士项目时，并没有真正寻求任何指导。然后当整个过程结束时，我只被一个项目录取了。所以我总是告诉学生，你只能去一所学校。所以只需要一个录取就够了。这是真的。但在当时，这感觉像是一个打击。
Don't get me wrong, I was actually really excited by the one option in front of me. But I had sort of imagined that I might have more choice when approaching this next big chapter of my life. And as you said, the one school I got into was in the Midwest, a place that I had never been for more than a few days. And so I was thinking a lot about what
别误会，我实际上对面前的唯一选择感到非常兴奋。但我曾想象在接近人生下一个大篇章时，我可能会有更多的选择。正如你所说，我被录取的唯一一所学校在中西部，一个我从未待过超过几天的地方。所以我当时想了很多关于
it would mean to be a gay man living in this different part of the country than I was used to. So how does this become a redemption story? It sounds actually the contamination is getting worse here, because you apply to all these colleges and you don't get into them. Right. So here's what happened.
作为一个同性恋男人生活在这个与我习惯的地方不同的国家部分意味着什么。那么这怎么变成了一个救赎故事？听起来实际上污染在这里变得更严重了，因为你申请了所有这些大学却没被录取。没错。所以发生了什么。
So I went to campus for my interview. And it was spring break week so no one was really around but after the the formal stuff was done I I sort of casually walked by the LGBT student groups office and there was this little yellow envelope of business cards tacked to the bulletin board outside that said something like questions? Email us at and then you know some generic email address. So when I got home I I sent this email saying, I'm thinking of coming here for graduate school,
我去校园参加面试。那是春假周，所以没什么人，但在正式的事情结束后，我随意地走过LGBT学生组织的办公室，公告栏外钉着一个小黄信封，里面装着名片，上面写着类似“有问题吗？发邮件给我们：”然后是一个通用的电子邮件地址。所以当我回家时，我发了这封邮件说，我正在考虑来这里读研究生，
I've never lived in the Midwest, what's it like to be there and be a gay person, both on campus and in the surrounding community? And we didn't even have internet at the house that I was renting with some friends, so I had to sneak into the computer lab at the nearby college to check my email. So a few days later, I got a perfectly nice and very thorough email
我从未在中西部生活过，在那里生活并作为一个同性恋者是什么感觉，无论是在校园还是在周边社区？我们租的房子里甚至没有互联网，所以我不得不溜进附近大学的计算机实验室去查看邮件。所以几天后，我收到了一封非常友好且非常详尽的邮件，
reassuring me from a senior undergrad about what it was like to go to school there and live in the town. And I'm sure it was a copy and paste of an email that he had sent many times before, but I appreciated how clear it was and the bits of humor sprinkled in. And I wrote back to say, you know, thanks, that was so super helpful. And then this student said, I'm actually graduating early, but I'm going to be hanging around. I'm handing off the listserv. But if you have questions, you know, just send me an email.
来自一位大四学生，他向我保证在那里上学和住在那个镇上是什么感觉。我敢肯定这是他以前发过很多次的邮件的复制粘贴，但我很欣赏它的清晰度，以及其中穿插的幽默感。我回信说，你知道，谢谢，这非常有帮助。然后这个学生说，我实际上要提前毕业了，但我会留在这里。我正在移交邮件列表。但如果你有问题，你知道，就给我发邮件。
And so quite a bit of time goes by and I did commit to going to school there. And when it was time for me to start looking for an apartment, I reached out again. And more than 20 years later, we are now married and have two kids and a dog. So those first emails weren't even remotely flirty, but they were attuned and connected and kind and funny and and eventually they did get flirty as did my responses and so I look back at this turning point in my life with a profound sense of first of all gratitude but also redemption right what at the time felt like close to failure right that all my work in college and all my ignoring of my personal life for the sake of my intellectual life had presented me with only one option,
所以过了相当长一段时间，我确实承诺去那里上学。当我要开始找公寓时，我又联系了他。20多年后的今天，我们现在结婚了，有两个孩子和一条狗。所以那些最初的邮件甚至一点都不调情，但它们很协调、有联系、善良且有趣，最终它们确实变得调情了，我的回复也是如此，所以我回顾我人生中的这个转折点，首先有一种深深的感激之情，但也有救赎，对吧？在当时感觉几乎是失败的事情，我大学所有的努力以及为了智力生活而忽视个人生活，只给了我一个选择，
now feels like the universe trying to make sure that I found my way. And within a year, I was having a more gratifying intellectual experience than I had ever imagined, and I was in love. I'm wondering in some ways if the narrative changing played some role in sort of these things happening in your life. Is it just that you had a series of bad luck and bad events happening to you, and then you had a series of bad luck and bad events happening to you, and then you had a series of good luck and good events happening to you?
现在感觉就像宇宙在试图确保我找到了自己的路。一年之内，我获得了比我曾经想象的更令人满足的智力体验，而且我恋爱了。我想知道在某种程度上，叙事的改变是否在这些事情发生在你生活中起到了一定作用。这只是因为你经历了一系列坏运气和坏事，然后你经历了一系列好运气和好事吗？
I mean, that might be the case, but that's not particularly interesting from a psychological point of view. Do you think that the way you were thinking about your own life and your exposure to Dan's ideas was, had reshaped your ability or your willingness to be open to thinking about a relationship in a different way
我的意思是，情况可能是这样，但从心理学角度来看，这并不是特别有趣。你认为你思考自己生活的方式以及你接触丹的思想，是否重塑了你以不同方式思考关系的能力或意愿，
or thinking about flirting on email with someone? Yeah, I really appreciate you bringing that up, because indeed, one could say, well, the objective facts where things were bad and then things were good, it really matters where we draw the chapter breaks in our lives. So yeah, one could say, well, that horrible chapter is over, and this new chapter is just a good chapter
或者思考在邮件中与某人调情？是的，我真的很感谢你提出这一点，因为确实，有人可能会说，好吧，客观事实是事情很糟糕，然后事情变好了，我们在人生中画章节断点的地方真的很重要。所以是的，有人可能会说，好吧，那个糟糕的章节结束了，这个新章节只是一个好章节。
But I actually think it is the way I have woven those two experiences together in my life story Where it feels like? Redemption instead of being a story where it was bad and then it was good this is a story that is about a shift from loneliness and compartmentalization to professional and personal fulfillment and identity integration. Notice where you start and stop Jonathan's story makes a profound difference about whether the story is a redemptive story or a contamination story. If you draw a connection between his unhappiness in college, his setbacks in Australia, and the fact he got into
但我实际上认为，正是因为我将这两种经历编织进我的人生故事中，它才感觉像是救赎，而不是一个坏事变好事的简单故事，这是一个关于从孤独和隔阂转向职业和个人成就以及身份整合的故事。注意你在哪里开始和结束，乔纳森的故事对于这个故事是救赎故事还是污染故事产生了深远的影响。如果你在他大学时的不快乐、他在澳大利亚的挫折，以及他努力工作后只被一所研究生院录取的事实之间建立联系，那个故事看起来就像是一连串无休止的挫折。另一方面，如果你讲述一个孤独的、隐瞒性取向的同性恋孩子的故事，他恰好被唯一一所他将在职业上成功、在个人生活上幸福的学校录取，那么它看起来就像天堂已经分开，一颗星星指引着乔纳森前进的方向。故事的客观事实没有改变，但你思考故事的方式却发生了深刻的变化。你可以在威廉·邓拉普和杰西卡·特雷西进行的一项研究中看到这一点有多强大。他们正在研究那些与成瘾作斗争的人讲述的故事。他们研究了个人叙事与在酒精依赖中导航的人保持清醒之间的关系。所以他们要求参与匿名戒酒互助会的人讲述他们最后一次喝酒的故事。他们实际上有两个样本，一个是已经保持清醒四年或更长时间的人，另一个是处于清醒初期阶段的样本。在这两组中，他们都发现，讲述最后一次喝酒的救赎故事的人比那些
only one graduate school after working so hard in college, that story looks like an endless loop of setbacks. On the other hand, if you tell the story of a lonely closeted gay kid who just happens to get into the one school where he is going to be professionally successful and personally happy, then it looks like the heavens have parted and a star is pointing the way forward for Jonathan. The objective facts of the story don't change, but the way you think of the story changes profoundly. You can see how powerful this is in a study conducted by William Dunlap and Jessica Tracy. They were researching the stories told by people fighting addiction. They looked at the relationship between personal narratives and the maintenance of sobriety among people navigating
故事中不包含救赎主题的人更有可能保持清醒。例如，他们谈到了一位参与者，他觉得对他来说最后一次喝酒确实象征着低谷。那是他承诺真正改变自己生活的时刻，他随后也确实做到了。这是该领域许多发现的象征，
alcohol dependence. So they asked people involved in Alcoholics Anonymous support groups to tell the story of their last drink. They actually had two samples, one of people who had remained sober for four years or longer, and another sample who were in the earliest stages of sobriety. And in both groups, they found that people who told redemptive stories of their last drink were more likely to stay sober than people
有些着眼于行为，有些主要着眼于心理健康结果，我们发现我们讲述的关于我们生活的故事是我们表现如何的强有力预测指标。乔纳森还发现，我们讲述生活故事的方式可以产生生物学影响。在一项研究中，乔纳森追踪了一组
whose stories didn't contain redemptive themes. So for example, they talk about one participant who felt like the last drink for him really symbolized the low point. And it was the moment when he committed to really turning his life around, which he then goes on to do. And that is emblematic of many findings in the field,
经历慢性压力的父母。该研究的合著者阿什利·梅森对端粒科学很感兴趣。所以端粒是染色体末端的保护帽，保护它们在每次细胞分裂时不会磨损或缠结，因为每次细胞分裂，它们都会变得越来越短，最终细胞失去保护并死亡。所以一些科学家将端粒长度视为衰老的生物标志物。
some that look at behavior, some that look mostly at mental health outcomes, where we find that the stories that we tell about our lives are strong predictors of how we're doing. Jonathan has also found that the way we tell stories about our lives can have biological effects. In one study, Jonathan tracked a group of parents
我们知道，在慢性压力条件下，端粒磨损得更快。所以在这项研究中，我们有一组慢性压力的参与者。这些是患有相当严重的自闭症谱系障碍儿童的父母，我们将他们与神经典型孩子的父母进行了比较，作为神经典型孩子的父母，这仍然是一种有压力的经历，但慢性压力的程度是不同的。所以我们在研究开始时收集了他们的故事，然后我们在第一个时间点测量了他们的幸福感以及关于他们端粒长度的数据，然后在18个月后再次测量。
experiencing chronic stress. His co-author on the study, Ashley Mason, was interested in the science of telomeres. So telomeres are the end caps on our chromosomes that protect them from getting frayed or tangled each time a cell divides, because each time the cell divides, they get shorter and shorter, and eventually the cell is left unprotected and it dies. So some scientists see telomere length as a biological marker of aging.
我们发现，在这些慢性压力的父母中，他们的故事非常重要。有趣的是，这项研究中的关键叙事主题不是救赎。这是一个整合的主题，我们思考参与者能够在多大程度上理解拥有这个具有挑战性的孩子，并将其整合到他们自己的人生故事中。所以我们发现，在慢性压力的父母中，整合的故事不仅与他们的自我报告相关，
And we know that under conditions of chronic stress, telomeres wear down faster. So in this study, we had a group of chronically stressed participants. These were parents who had children with quite severe autism spectrum disorders, and we compared them to parents of neurotypical kids, which as a parent of neurotypical kids is still a stressful experience, but the degree of chronic stress is different. So we had their stories at the beginning of the study, and then we had measures of their well-being and also data about their telomere length at that first time point, and then again 18 months later.
即较低水平的心理压力，而且与18个月内端粒缩短显著减少有关。据我所知，这是唯一一项显示人们叙事中的主题与压力和衰老的生物标志物之间存在联系的研究，但这表明我们的故事可能存在生物学后果，而不仅仅是心理后果。父母在他们讲述的故事类型方面说了什么，关于
And what we found was that among these chronically stressed parents, their stories mattered a lot. What was interesting was that the key narrative theme in this study was not redemption. It was a theme of integration where we think about the extent to which participants were able to make sense of having had this challenging kid and integrating that into their own life story. So we found that among the chronically stressed parents, stories of integration were associated not only with their self-report
有效或不太有效的故事。研究中的一位父母谈到了育儿是终极人生考验的方式，她是这么说的。她说，你知道，你可以读很多关于这些东西的书，但最终你必须向你的孩子学习。对她来说，这教会了她很多关于她是谁
of lower levels of psychological stress, but also with significantly less telomere shortening over 18 months. So as far as I know, this is the only study to show a connection between the themes in people's narratives and biological markers of stress and aging, but it suggests that there may be biological consequences of our stories, not just psychological ones. What did the parents say in terms of the kinds of stories they told, in terms of stories
作为一个人的信息，她是如何开放或不开放的，以及她觉得拥有这种具有挑战性的育儿经历确实帮助她重塑了她作为一个人的身份，以及对于她来说，不仅是作为一个父母，而且是作为一个与她深爱的另一个人建立关系的人意味着什么。现在，当你听到有人讲述一个救赎故事，并且你看到他们正在经历更好的心理健康时，就会出现一个问题，那就是因果箭头的方向是什么？他们是在讲述救赎故事
that were effective or less effective. One of the parents in the study talked about the ways in which parenting is the ultimate life test, is what she said. And she said, you know, you can read a ton about all this stuff, but ultimately you have to learn from your kid. And for her, that taught her a lot about who she was
因此对他们的生活感觉更好吗？还是他们对他们的生活感觉更好，因此讲述了救赎故事？有一次，你追踪了一组与心理治疗师合作的患者，你记录了他们在治疗过程中经历的变化，以及他们讲述的关于他们生活的故事，还有哪个先于哪个。你发现了什么，乔纳森？是的，我变得痴迷于那个方向性问题。在那项研究中，我招募了一群人，年龄从18岁到92岁的成年人。他们正在寻求个人治疗
as a person, how she was open and not open, and how she felt like having this challenging parenting experience really helped her reshape who she was as a person and what it meant to her to not only be a parent, but a human in relation with this other human who she loved dearly. Now, when you hear someone tell a redemptive story and you see that they are experiencing better mental health, there is a question that arises, which is, in which direction does the arrow of causation run? Are they telling redemptive stories
针对各种各样的问题。所以有患有非常严重的精神病理学的人，比如抑郁症、焦虑症、饮食失调。但也有人只是想在自己身上做一些工作。有一位女性想在即将成为母亲时思考她自己的童年。
and therefore feeling better about their lives? Or are they feeling better about their lives and therefore telling redemptive stories? At one point, you followed a group of patients as they worked with a psychotherapist and you charted both the changes they experienced while in therapy and the stories they told about their lives and also which preceded which. What did you find, Jonathan? Yeah, I became obsessed with that directionality question. In that study, I enrolled a bunch of people, adults ranging from ages 18 to 92. They were seeking individual therapy
有一位女性在退休后感到孤独。所以在他们开始与治疗师合作之前，我们收集了他们的故事，并使用标准测量方法测量了他们的幸福感。所以在那之后，我们从所有这些参与者那里收集了近600个叙事。我们发现的是，首先，
for a huge range of problems. So there were folks with really significant psychopathology, like depression, anxiety, eating disorders. But there were also people just wanting to do some work on themselves. There was a woman who wanted to think through her own childhood as she was about to become a parent.
人们在治疗过程中变得更好，这很好，因为几十年来关于心理治疗的研究表明它是有效的。我们发现人们的故事在治疗过程中以有意义的方式发生了变化。故事的变化实际上先于幸福感的变化，而不是相反。因为这就像人们在叙述他们生活的新版本，然后一周
There was a woman who was feeling lonely in retirement. So before they started with their therapist, we collected their stories and we measured their wellbeing using standard measures. And so then on the other side, we had nearly 600 narratives from across all these participants. And what we found was, first,
或两周后，他们的幸福感会赶上故事。当我们走过人生，应对不可预测的起伏时，感觉就像我们是生活事件的人质。这就是为什么许多人认为命运之手在他们身上发生的事情中起作用。但一旦我们意识到我们不仅是人生故事中一个饱受折磨的角色，我们也是作者，一切看起来就不同了。当我们回来时，讲述关于我们生活更明智故事的四个原则。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当你听这段对话时，你对叙事心理学有什么问题或评论吗？你是如何讲述你的
people got better over the course of treatment, which is good because decades of research on psychotherapy suggests that it works. And we found that people's stories changed in meaningful ways over the course of treatment. And then the changes in the story actually came before changes in well-being and not the other way around. Because it was as if people were narrating a new version of their lives and then a week
生活故事的，这又是如何塑造你看待自己的方式的？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享你的想法，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“个人故事”。我们所有人都在不断构建关于我们生活的故事。大多数时候，这发生在表面之下。我们没有意识到我们所做的叙事选择。然而，每隔一段时间，我们的生活中就会发生一些事情，导致我们重新审视我们的故事。
or two later, their well-being would catch up with the story. As we go through our lives responding to ups and downs that come at us unpredictably, it can feel as if we are hostages to life events. This is why many people see the hand of fate in the things that happen to them. But everything looks different once we realize that we are not simply a beleaguered character in our life story, we are also the author. When we come back, four principles to tell wiser stories about our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. As you listen to this conversation, do you have questions or comments about narrative psychology? How do you tell the story of your
婚姻、离婚、孩子的出生、亲密朋友的去世。所有这些都需要时间来融入一个亲密朋友的叙事中。所有这些都需要时间来融入我们生活的叙事中。在欧林工程学院，心理学家乔纳森·阿德勒研究了当挑战我们既有叙事的事件出现时会发生什么。约翰，我想让你给我讲讲一位名叫安妮·布鲁斯特的医生的故事。你能描述一下安妮的生活是怎样的吗？
life and how does that shape the way you see yourself? If you're comfortable sharing your thoughts with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, personal stories. All of us constantly construct stories about our lives. Most of the time, this happens under the surface. We are not mindful of the narrative choices we make. Every so often, however, something happens in our lives that causes us to revisit our stories.
生活，以及这如何塑造了你看待自己的方式？如果你愿意与Hidden Brain的听众分享你的想法，请用手机录一段语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至ideas@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请注明“个人故事”。我们每个人都在不断地构建关于自己生活的故事。大多数时候，这一切都在潜意识中发生。我们并没有意识到自己所做的叙事选择。然而，每隔一段时间，我们的生活中就会发生一些事情，促使我们重新审视自己的故事。
A marriage, a divorce, the birth of a child, the death of a close friend. All of these take time to assimilate into the narrative of a close friend. All of these take time to assimilate into the narrative of our lives. At Olin College of Engineering, psychologist Jonathan Adler has studied what happens when events come along that challenge our pre-existing narratives. John, I want you to tell me the story of a physician named Annie Brewster. Can you describe what Annie's life was
结婚、离婚、孩子的出生、挚友的离世。所有这些都需要时间来融入我们生活的叙事中。在欧林工程学院，心理学家乔纳森·阿德勒研究了当挑战我们既有叙事的事件发生时会发生什么。约翰，我想请你讲讲一位名叫安妮·布鲁斯特的医生的故事。你能描述一下安妮的生活吗？
like when she was in her late 20s? Annie was one of these unbelievably driven, successful students. She was, had done extremely well in medical school, landed a great residency, was working a million hours, but she had started to experience some tingling on one side of her body and she went to get it checked out and, you know, she was very well connected in the medical sphere and waited to see the Uber specialist who quite brusquely told her that she had multiple sclerosis. I want to play a bit of tape here from Annie herself talking about how she reacted to the news from her doctor.
比如她二十多岁的时候？安妮曾是那种极其上进、事业有成的学生。她医学院成绩优异，顺利进入了理想的住院医师项目，工作强度极大。但后来她身体一侧开始出现刺痛感，于是去做了检查。由于她在医疗界人脉很广，她等待着去见那位顶尖专家，结果对方却非常生硬地告诉她，她患上了多发性硬化症。我想播放一段安妮本人的录音，听听她当时对医生告知这一消息的反应。
It took me a long time to come to terms with that diagnosis, to accept it into my life. Really it was difficult for me because I'd always thought of myself as somebody who was really strong. My body had always worked for me, done what I wanted it to do. And to think of myself as someone with an illness, I really had to redefine myself and get over some denial. Jonathan, you say that Annie was engaging in an internal process of accommodation.
我花了很长时间才接受这个诊断，才把它融入我的生活。这对我来说真的很困难，因为我一直认为自己是一个非常坚强的人。我的身体一直很听话，我想做什么它就能做什么。而现在要将自己视为一个病人，我真的必须重新定义自己，并克服某种否认心理。乔纳森，你说安妮当时正在进行一种内在的适应过程。
What do you mean by this? And is accommodation a good thing? So most of what we do most of the time, we call assimilation. We go on living our lives, and when new things happen, we just assimilate those experiences into the story that we've been telling, whether we do that consciously or not. But sometimes something happens that really makes us question
你这话是什么意思？适应是一件好事吗？我们大多数时候所做的大部分事情，我们称之为“同化”。我们继续过着自己的生活，当新事物发生时，我们只是将这些经历融入到我们一直在讲述的故事中，无论我们是否有意识地这样做。但有时发生的事情确实会让我们质疑
the story we've been telling. And in those instances, the story itself needs to change to accommodate that new experience. And what we call accommodative processing is a key narrative variable in supporting our well-being, but it doesn't support our well-being in exactly the way redemption does, for example. But accommodative processing, it helps us feel like our life has meaning and we understand it, even if it doesn't always feel good. And so Annie tells this story that once she did finally start to accommodate this experience,
我们一直在讲述的故事。在这些情况下，故事本身需要改变以适应这种新的体验。我们所说的“适应性加工”是支持我们幸福感的一个关键叙事变量，但它支持幸福感的方式与“救赎”等方式并不完全相同。不过，适应性加工能帮助我们感受到生活的意义，让我们理解生活，即使这种感觉并不总是愉快的。安妮讲述了这样一个故事：一旦她最终开始适应这种经历，
when she did really start to reshape her identity to include this idea of herself as having an illness, she stepped away from her very prestigious medical career. She went down to part-time and she founded a nonprofit organization called Health Story Collaborative. And I met Annie about a year into that process, and she was going around and collecting other people's stories and curating them. And 10 years later, we have worked really closely together developing programs that leverage the science of narrative in order to support storytelling in the highly fragmented and fragmenting medical ecosystem.
当她真正开始重塑自己的身份，将“自己患有疾病”这一观念纳入其中时，她离开了自己非常显赫的医疗职业。她转为兼职，并创办了一家名为“健康故事协作”（Health Story Collaborative）的非营利组织。我在那个过程开始大约一年后遇到了安妮，当时她正在四处收集他人的故事并进行整理。十年后，我们紧密合作，开发了一些项目，利用叙事科学来支持在高度碎片化且不断分裂的医疗生态系统中进行故事讲述。
When we modify our life stories to accommodate new life events, those events no longer feel random and aberrational. The less we feel buffeted by random events, the more we feel like we are in control of our own lives. This leads to the next idea. Jonathan has found that stories that give us a feeling that we are in charge of our own lives are linked to higher well-being. Agency is a theme in people's stories. We assess it along a continuum from sort of being able to
当我们修改自己的人生故事以适应新的生活事件时，这些事件就不再显得随机和反常。我们越少感到被随机事件所左右，就越觉得自己在掌控自己的生活。这引出了下一个观点。乔纳森发现，那些让我们感到自己掌控生活的故事与更高的幸福感相关联。自主性是人们故事中的一个主题。我们沿着一个连续体来评估它，从某种程度上能够
direct your life and then down at the other end of the continuum you're sort of batted around by the whims of fate. And again these are themes and stories. No one is completely in control of their lives so it's the way you portray the main character in the story, i.e. you. Jonathan cites the remarkable story of a woman named Leila. So in the last five years, I've been doing a lot of research focused on identity development among people who acquire physical disabilities. And Lela was a participant in one of my studies. She tells this story of having these horrible headaches, which gradually intensified to the point where she couldn't function.
主导你的人生，到连续体的另一端，即你被命运的反复无常所摆布。同样，这些都是故事中的主题。没有人能完全掌控自己的生活，所以关键在于你如何塑造故事中的主角，也就是你自己。乔纳森引用了一位名叫莱拉的女性的非凡故事。在过去的五年里，我做了大量研究，专注于获得性身体残疾人群的身份发展。莱拉是我研究的参与者之一。她讲述了自己经历剧烈头痛的故事，头痛逐渐加剧，直到她无法正常生活。
She spends time in three different hospitals in Nairobi, Kenya, where she lives. And no one can figure out what's going on. She decides to fly to India to see a specialist, and he sends her right into surgery, and when she wakes up, the pain is gone. But she also can't see, and the surgeon had been able to alleviate
她在肯尼亚内罗毕的三家不同医院度过了一段时间，但没人能查出原因。她决定飞往印度去看专家，医生直接安排她进行了手术。当她醒来时，疼痛消失了。但她也看不见了，外科医生虽然成功缓解了
the unexplained swelling in her head that had been pressing on her optic nerves, but the nerve was also irreparably damaged. So for a few months, everyone held out hope that her vision might return, but Layla was actually the first one to accept that it wouldn't. She said, I realized as soon as I started accepting it, I started becoming less frustrated and sad. And though it was incredibly difficult and scary for her, Layla gradually threw herself into the task of becoming a blind person.
她头部压迫视神经的无法解释的肿胀，但神经也受到了不可逆转的损伤。几个月来，每个人都抱着希望，认为她的视力可能会恢复，但莱拉实际上是第一个接受视力不会恢复的人。她说：“我意识到，当我开始接受它时，我开始变得不那么沮丧和悲伤了。”尽管这对她来说极其困难和可怕，但莱拉逐渐全身心地投入到成为一名盲人的任务中。
So she shifts careers, she moves to the United States to get training in computer science, where she starts working on adaptive technology for other blind and low vision people. I want to play a clip of Leila talking about her experience. Here she is. I think my blindness is the best thing that ever happened to me. Even right now, if a doctor came here and told me they have a cure, I would not take it.
于是她转行了，搬到美国接受计算机科学培训，开始为其他盲人和低视力人群开发辅助技术。我想播放一段莱拉讲述她经历的片段。听听看。我觉得失明是我发生过的最好的事情。即使现在，如果有一位医生来到这里告诉我他们有治愈的方法，我也不会接受。
Because I think for me, it made me understand myself and it made me like it gives me these new challenges every single day. It presents me with something and through those challenges I'm able to understand myself. So that's a remarkable account Jonathan but as I hear Leila talking I feel like I've heard the same thing in the deaf community. Many deaf people today say, you know, the real problem is not with deafness. I just happen to speak sign language. I speak a different language than you do. Now we can all debate how and whether something should be considered a disorder. But I think the point you're trying to make here is that the stories we tell can either put us in the driver's seat or put us in the passenger's seat, and Leila is clearly choosing to be in the driver's
因为我认为对我来说，它让我了解了自己，它让我……它每天都给我带来新的挑战。它向我展示了一些东西，通过这些挑战，我能够了解自己。乔纳森，这是一个非凡的叙述，但当我听到莱拉说话时，我觉得我在聋人社区也听到过同样的话。今天许多聋人说，你知道，真正的问题不在于耳聋。我只是碰巧说手语。我说的语言和你不同。现在我们可以争论某件事是否应该被视为一种障碍。但我认为你想表达的观点是，我们讲述的故事要么让我们坐在驾驶座上，要么让我们坐在乘客座上，而莱拉显然选择了坐在驾驶座上。
seat. That's right. Traditional models of disability in the United States have this medical approach where disability is a problem to be solved or eradicated, and social models of disability or relational models really push back on that and say, disability is in the interaction between my body and the built and social environment around us. In Layla's story, like you said,
没错。美国传统的残疾模式采取的是一种医疗方法，即残疾是一个需要解决或根除的问题；而残疾的社会模式或关系模式则对此进行了反驳，认为残疾存在于我的身体与我们周围的建筑和社会环境之间的互动中。在莱拉的故事里，正如你所说，
there's also this sense of agency. Now that this is part of who I am, what am I gonna do with it? How can I take control of this and use it for things that matter to me? You can see a theme emerging here. As you tell the story of your life, do you see yourself as a passive subject, someone to whom things happen, or as an active protagonist, someone who is directing the course of her own life?
也有一种自主感。既然这是我的一部分，我该拿它怎么办？我怎样才能掌控它并将其用于对我重要的事情上？你可以看到这里出现了一个主题。当你讲述自己的人生故事时，你把自己看作是一个被动的客体，一个事情发生在其身上的人，还是一个积极的主角，一个正在主导自己人生进程的人？
Now as Jonathan says, every life offers lots of evidence that allows you to draw either conclusion. Given this, Jonathan is saying, choose narratives that put you in the driver's seat. Most of the narratives we have discussed so far have championed the idea of the individual. But it's also the case that no man is an island. Yeah, so in our conversation so far, we've been very focused on individuals. But of course, we aren't these isolated individuals. We're all connected. And communion is a theme that captures the quality
正如乔纳森所说，每个人的人生都提供了大量证据，让你得出任何一个结论。鉴于此，乔纳森建议，选择那些让你坐在驾驶座上的叙事。我们目前讨论的大多数叙事都支持个人的理念。但同样真实的是，没有人是一座孤岛。是的，在我们目前的对话中，我们非常关注个人。但当然，我们并不是这些孤立的个体。我们都是相互联系的。而“共融”是一个捕捉人们与他人联系质量的主题。
of people's connections to others. So in my research with people who have disabilities, there's often a lot of talk about their connections not only with family and friends and co-workers, but with the broader disability community. So at Olin College, you help organize a yearly event called a Story Slam, at which students perform renditions of their stories, tell about the events in their lives. And in advance of one year slam, you worked with a student named Antonio.
所以在我和残疾人的研究中，经常会谈到他们不仅与家人、朋友和同事，而且与更广泛的残疾人社区之间的联系。在奥林学院，你帮助组织了一年一度的活动，叫做“故事大满贯”（Story Slam），学生们在活动中表演他们的故事，讲述他们生活中的事件。在某一年的大满贯活动之前，你和一位名叫安东尼奥的学生合作过。
What was his story, Jonathan? Yeah, so Antonio was really interested in thinking through what it meant to him to be a first generation Latino student at this small engineering college. And he, he described feeling isolated, um, during his weekend on campus as a prospective student. It wasn't the conversations about science that made him feel left out. It really was the small talk.
他的故事是什么，乔纳森？是的，安东尼奥非常热衷于思考作为这所小型工程学院的第一代拉丁裔学生对他意味着什么。他描述了自己在校园度过周末作为准学生时感到孤立。让他感到被排斥的并不是关于科学的对话，而是闲聊。
So he has this great line in the story where he says, I'm definitely not fluent in cheese. And what he means is that disconnection gets coded into even the most mundane experiences, not just the grand low points of our lives. But as isolated as he was feeling, Antonia homed in, not on his isolation, but on a moment of connection.
他在故事里有一句很棒的话，他说：“我绝对不精通‘奶酪’（社交闲聊）。”他的意思是，脱节感甚至会编码进最平凡的经历中，而不仅仅是我们生活中重大的低谷。但尽管他感到孤立，安东尼奥关注的不是他的孤立，而是一个连接的时刻。
I think I finally found somebody who understood. connection. I think I finally found somebody who understood. Diego was a person who had also danced at Quintaneras, who had also brought lunch in a repurposed sour cream container and applied to the same college scholarships for low-income students. One would even think we had done all these things side by side. So I can hear the theme of positive communion here, Jonathan. Antonio is telling a story that says, I'm not alone. Exactly.
我想我终于找到了一个能理解的人。连接。我想我终于找到了一个能理解的人。迭戈也是一个曾在成人礼上跳过舞、也曾用重复利用的酸奶盒带午餐、并申请了同样针对低收入学生奖学金的人。人们甚至会以为我们并肩做过所有这些事情。所以我能听到这里积极共融的主题，乔纳森。安东尼奥讲述的故事是说，我并不孤单。没错。
In this room full of people who did not look like him, Antonio found someone who did, and they really connected. And he says, you know, Diego threw down this challenge. If you think there should be more people like us here, then come and fix it. And Antonio says, you know, I'm a competitive guy and the next fall I was on a one-way bus trip to Olin College.
在这个满屋子长得不像他的人的房间里，安东尼奥找到了一个和他一样的人，他们真的建立了联系。他说，你知道，迭戈提出了这个挑战：如果你认为这里应该有更多像我们这样的人，那就来改变它。安东尼奥说，你知道，我是一个好胜的人，第二年秋天，我就坐上了去往奥林学院的单程巴士。
So Jonathan, one final feature of a constructive story is that it generates meaning for the person who tells it. You say we're not always able to tell a happy story about what happens to us, but we can try and tell a meaningful story and there are benefits to telling such stories. Can you explain what you mean? Yeah, so to pan back for just a second, when we think about the broad study of wellbeing,
乔纳森，建设性故事的最后一个特征是它为讲述者创造了意义。你说我们并不总能讲述一个关于我们所经历之事的快乐故事，但我们可以尝试讲述一个有意义的故事，而讲述这样的故事是有益的。你能解释一下你的意思吗？是的，稍微退后一步来看，当我们思考幸福感的广泛研究时，
it tends to cluster in sort of two domains, which get their cumbersome names from Aristotle. So on the one hand, we have what's called hedonic well-being, which means it feels good. And on the other hand, we have a kind of well-being called eudaimonic well-being, which means it feels meaningful. And these two domains of well-being are actually relatively uncorrelated with each other. And if we think about our lives for a second, that makes sense, right?
它往往集中在两个领域，这两个领域从亚里士多德那里获得了它们笨拙的名称。一方面，我们有所谓的“享乐主义幸福感”，意思是感觉良好；另一方面，我们有一种叫做“幸福感”（eudaimonic well-being）的幸福感，意思是感觉有意义。这两个幸福感领域实际上彼此之间相关性相对较低。如果我们思考一下我们的生活，这说得通，对吧？
We all do plenty of things that feel good, but don't feel particularly meaningful, like we might binge watch TV or something. And we can all think about experiences that feel meaningful, but don't feel particularly good. So in my work with Health Story Collaborative in particular, we find that feeling good is not always an option for people. Telling redemptive stories or stories high in the theme of agency and communion, that's not always possible.
我们都做了很多感觉良好但并不特别有意义的事情，比如我们可能会狂看电视之类的。我们也都能想到一些感觉有意义但并不特别愉快的事情。所以，特别是在我与“健康故事协作”的工作中，我们发现感觉良好并不总是人们的选择。讲述救赎故事，或者充满自主和共融主题的故事，并不总是可能的。
And in those situations, we're often interested in the ways in which people can really think through the hard parts of their lives and find some meaning out of that. And even if the meaning doesn't ultimately feel good in that sort of happy sense, that meaning is still incredibly worthwhile. I'm trying to imagine how someone who is going through a rough time might hear this episode, Jonathan, and I worry that that person might say, you know, I've just lost my job. I've just gotten divorced. I've just lost a close family friend.
在这些情况下，我们通常感兴趣的是人们如何真正深入思考他们生活中的困难部分并从中找到一些意义。即使这种意义最终在那种快乐的意义上并不让人感觉良好，这种意义仍然是非常值得的。乔纳森，我试着想象一个正在经历艰难时期的人可能会如何听到这一集，我担心那个人可能会说，你知道，我刚丢了工作。我刚离婚。我刚失去了一位亲密的家庭朋友。
And now Jonathan Adler comes along and tells me that if I'm unhappy, it's because I'm not telling the right story about my life. How would you respond to that? I want to say three things to that person. The first thing is, I'm sorry. I'm sorry that things are so hard for you right now. Of course, they're hard, and of course, you're not feeling good. The second thing I want to say is, there
现在乔纳森·阿德勒来了，告诉我如果我不快乐，是因为我没有讲述关于我生活的正确故事。你会如何回应？我想对那个人说三件事。第一件事是，我很抱歉。我很抱歉你现在处境如此艰难。当然，它们很艰难，当然，你感觉不好。第二件事我想说的是，
are all kinds of ways of making meaning of these experiences. And so we might think about exploring themes of agency or communion. So if you lost your job, are you feeling connected to your spouse or your kids? Or, you know, if something challenging has happened, might there be some growth that comes from it? So we might explore those themes. But the third thing I want to say is our personal stories exist in a broader narrative ecosystem. And in the United States, there is an expectation that we can narrate challenging experiences in our lives with a redemptive spin. We Americans love the theme of redemption, and we expect people to be able to do it. And I call this the press of redemption and we expect people to be able to do it and I call
赋予这些经历意义的方法有很多种。所以我们可以考虑探索自主或共融的主题。如果你丢了工作，你是否感到与配偶或孩子有联系？或者，你知道，如果发生了什么具有挑战性的事情，是否会从中产生一些成长？所以我们可以探索这些主题。但第三件事我想说的是，我们的个人故事存在于一个更广泛的叙事生态系统中。在美国，有一种期望，即我们能够以救赎的视角来叙述我们生活中的挑战性经历。我们美国人热爱救赎的主题，并期望人们能够做到这一点。我称之为“救赎的压力”，我称之为
this the press for redemption and in my work with Health Story Collaborative we often find that people feel like they're having this double whammy experience where you know I'm sick and I'm not telling the right kind of story about it so my cancer didn't teach me that I'm such a fighter or that people love me more than I ever would have realized if I never had cancer. No, some people say, you know, this just sucks. And I think in those instances, we want to acknowledge that and not try to convince them that it doesn't just suck. Let them know that there's a reason they feel like they're telling the wrong kind of story, because our culture puts a particular premium on a particular kind of story, and then to help them find other
“救赎的压力”。在我和“健康故事协作”的工作中，我们经常发现人们觉得他们正在经历这种双重打击：你知道，我生病了，但我没有讲述关于它的正确故事，所以我的癌症并没有教会我我是一个多么坚强的斗士，或者如果我从未得过癌症，我就永远不会意识到人们比我预想的更爱我。不，有些人说，你知道，这简直糟透了。我认为在这些情况下，我们想要承认这一点，而不是试图说服他们这并不糟透了。让他们知道他们觉得自己在讲述错误类型的故事是有原因的，因为我们的文化对特定类型的故事给予了特别的重视，然后帮助他们找到其他
kinds of narrative roots that might lead towards a sense of meaningfulness, even if they can't make you feel better. So many of the examples we've talked about here have involved individuals, but as we've started to see, I think, towards the end of this conversation, we're slowly broadening out beyond the individual. Because of course, these ideas are relevant outside of individual minds as well. So societies tell themselves narratives.
类型的叙事根源，这些根源可能会引导人们产生一种意义感，即使它们不能让你感觉更好。我们在这里讨论的许多例子都涉及个人，但正如我们开始看到的那样，我认为，在这次对话接近尾声时，我们正在慢慢超越个人。因为当然，这些想法在个人思想之外也是相关的。所以社会也在讲述叙事。
Nations tell themselves stories all the time. Do you think ideas of narrative psychology speak to how nations talk to themselves and perhaps how they ought to talk to themselves? I do. And this is really at the forefront of the field. So my colleagues Kate McLean and Moin Syed have written really compellingly about what
国家一直在讲述自己的故事。你认为叙事心理学的观点是否说明了国家如何与自己对话，以及也许它们应该如何与自己对话？我认为是这样。这确实处于该领域的前沿。所以我的同事凯特·麦克莱恩和莫因·赛义德写了非常有说服力的文章，关于他们所说的
they call master narratives. So these are the dominant storylines in our culture that tend to be invisible, but also ubiquitous and sort of rigid and powerful. And we are always in a constant dialogue with the master narratives in our particular cultural contexts. Families have narratives that guide the way relationships unfold, and as you said, countries certainly do. So again, narratives are not all good or all bad at the individual level and they're not all good or all bad at the
“主叙事”。这些是我们文化中占主导地位的故事线，它们往往是隐形的，但也是无处不在的，而且某种程度上是僵化和强大的。我们始终与我们特定文化背景下的主叙事进行着持续的对话。家庭有指导关系展开方式的叙事，正如你所说，国家当然也有。所以再次强调，叙事在个人层面并非全好或全坏，在
at the national level either, but these national narratives are emergent from the collection of individual narratives that the members of that country tell. So a number of years ago, Jonathan, when you were still living in Illinois, the junior senator from your state gave a memorable speech at the 2004 Democratic National Convention. I want to play you a clip from the speech that first put Barack Obama in the national spotlight. I'm not talking about blind optimism here. The almost willful ignorance that thinks unemployment will go away if we just don't think about it, or health care crisis will solve itself if we just ignore it. That's not what I'm talking about.
国家层面也并非全好或全坏，但这些国家叙事是从该国成员讲述的个人叙事集合中涌现出来的。乔纳森，多年前你还住在伊利诺伊州时，你们州的初级参议员在2004年民主党全国代表大会上发表了一次令人难忘的演讲。我想播放一段让巴拉克·奥巴马首次进入全国聚光灯下的演讲片段。我说的不是盲目的乐观。那种认为如果我们不去想，失业就会消失，或者如果我们忽视它，医疗危机就会自行解决的近乎故意的无知。那不是我在说的。
I'm talking about something more substantial. It's the hope of slaves sitting around a fire singing freedom songs. The hope of immigrants setting out for distant shores. The hope of a young naval lieutenant bravely patrolling the Mekong Delta. The hope of a mill worker's son who dares to defy the odds. The hope of a skinny kid with a funny name who believes that America has a place for him too. Hope in the face of difficulty. Hope in the face of uncertainty. The audacity of hope. In the end, that is God's greatest gift to us, the bedrock of this nation. A belief in things not seen. A belief that there are better days ahead.
我说的是更实质性的东西。那是奴隶们围坐在火堆旁唱着自由之歌的希望。是移民们前往遥远海岸的希望。是年轻的海军中尉勇敢地巡逻湄公河三角洲的希望。是磨坊工人的儿子敢于挑战困难的希望。是一个名字滑稽的瘦弱孩子，他相信美国也有他的一席之地。面对困难时的希望。面对不确定性时的希望。希望的勇气。最终，那是上帝赐予我们最伟大的礼物，是这个国家的基石。对未见之事的信念。相信未来会有更好的日子。
I'm wondering, Jonathan, as someone who has studied narrative psychology for a number of years, how do you hear that speech? So then Senator Obama was tapping into the American master narrative of redemption. Each of those images includes this shift from negative to positive. And like all political speeches, this
乔纳森，作为一名研究叙事心理学多年的学者，我想知道你是如何听这段演讲的？当时的奥巴马参议员正在利用美国的救赎主叙事。每一个意象都包含了这种从负面到正面的转变。像所有政治演讲一样，这
was a strategic communication with very particular aims, focused on stirring the public to support this speaker's preferred candidates and issues. So appealing to entrenched master narratives is a very strategic thing to do. And many, many politicians adopt redemptive themes in their speeches. And obviously there are many wonderful aspects of that storyline and as we've discussed problematic ones too, but we see evidence of leaders serving as narrators in chief. They shape our narrative
是一种有着非常具体目标的战略传播，旨在激励公众支持演讲者偏好的候选人和议题。所以诉诸根深蒂固的主叙事是一件非常有策略的事情。许多许多政治家在演讲中采用了救赎主题。显然，那个故事线有很多精彩的方面，正如我们讨论过的，也有问题的方面，但我们看到领导者作为“首席叙述者”的证据。他们塑造了我们的叙事
ecology as they model storytelling for us. We started this conversation, Jonathan, by talking about ways in which you came to understand the life events in your own life and to tell stories about those life events in a way that was more positive than negative. I'm wondering, after all these years of studying narrative psychology, do you do this on a regular basis now?
生态，因为他们为我们示范了如何讲故事。乔纳森，我们开始这次对话时，谈到了你理解自己生活中事件的方式，以及以一种更积极而非消极的方式讲述这些生活事件的故事。我想知道，在研究了这么多年的叙事心理学之后，你现在还会定期这样做吗？
What are the stories you tell yourself today in terms of where you are and where your life is and where you want your life to go? So it's not that I am consciously going through my daily experiences and editing them into the kinds of storylines that I have learned are likely to support my well-being. But when difficult things happen in particular, I think I do pause and I remember that there are different kinds of well-being and that the way I make sense of those experiences will lead me to different kinds of well-being. But I think for a lot of people, just the awareness that you are not only the main character in your story, but also the narrator,
就你所处的位置、你的人生阶段以及你希望人生走向何方而言，你今天对自己讲述的是什么样的故事？并不是说我会有意识地经历日常体验，并将它们编辑成我所学到的可能支持我幸福感的故事线。但特别是当困难的事情发生时，我想我确实会停下来，记住幸福感有不同的种类，我理解这些经历的方式将引导我走向不同种类的幸福感。但我认为对于许多人来说，仅仅意识到你不仅是故事中的主角，也是叙述者，
and that the way you choose to tell the story of your life really matters, that can be an empowering insight. Jonathan Adler is a psychologist at Olin College. Jonathan, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, it's been an incredible pleasure. Thank you for inviting me. Do you have follow-up questions or ideas that you'd like to share after listening to this episode? How do you tell the story of your life, and how does that shape the way you see yourself? If you're comfortable sharing your thoughts with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org.
而且你选择讲述人生故事的方式确实很重要，这可能是一个赋予力量的洞察。乔纳森·阿德勒是奥林学院的心理学家。乔纳森，非常感谢你今天参加“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）。哦，这真是莫大的荣幸。谢谢你的邀请。听完这一集后，你有什么后续问题或想法想分享吗？你如何讲述你的人生故事，这又是如何塑造你看待自己的方式的？如果你愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享你的想法，请在手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。
Use the subject line, personal stories. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Think about the last time you entered a negotiation. Perhaps you were asking your boss for a raise or trying to get your child to do their chores. What was your strategy as you headed into the discussion? Often, our focus is on what we want to get out of the interaction.
请使用主题行“个人故事”。再次重复那个电子邮件地址，ideas@hiddenbrain.org。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。想想你上次进入谈判的情景。也许你是在向老板要求加薪，或者试图让你的孩子做家务。当你进入讨论时，你的策略是什么？通常，我们的重点是我们想从互动中得到什么。
Any planning we do is focused on how to put our best case forward. But behavioral scientist Max Bezerman offers a different approach. He's at Harvard Business School and author of the book Negotiation, The Game Has Changed. Max says instead of focusing on our goals, we should focus on our blind spots. We recently talked with Max on Hidden Brain. Those episodes are titled Relationships 2.0 Become a Better Negotiator and for our Hidden Brain Plus subscribers Relationships 2.0 Win-Win. Today as part of our ongoing series Your Questions Answered we asked Max to come back
我们所做的任何计划都集中在如何提出我们最好的理由。但行为科学家马克斯·巴泽曼提供了一种不同的方法。他在哈佛商学院任教，是《谈判：游戏规则已变》（Negotiation, The Game Has Changed）一书的作者。马克斯说，我们不应该关注我们的目标，而应该关注我们的盲点。我们最近在“隐藏的大脑”节目中与马克斯进行了交谈。那些剧集标题为《关系2.0：成为更好的谈判者》，对于我们的“隐藏的大脑Plus”订阅者，标题为《关系2.0：双赢》。今天，作为我们正在进行的系列节目“你的问题已解答”的一部分，我们请马克斯回到
on the show to answer your questions about negotiation. Max Baserman, welcome back to Hidden Brain. I'm delighted to be back and I look forward to hearing the questions that are in the minds of your listeners. So Max, it's understandable that we're often immersed in our own perspectives during a negotiation, but in doing so, you say that we can become biased in our own perspectives, biased by our own needs. How so, Max?
节目中来回答你关于谈判的问题。马克斯·巴泽曼，欢迎回到“隐藏的大脑”。我很高兴回来，我很期待听到听众心中的问题。那么马克斯，在谈判过程中我们经常沉浸在自己的视角中是可以理解的，但你说这样做会让我们在自己的视角中产生偏见，被自己的需求所左右。马克斯，这是怎么回事？
So once we know what role we're in, what side we're playing, what our interests are, our ability to be objective largely disappears. So if we have, let's say a plaintiff and a defendant in a lawsuit, and we ask them to reveal to us what they think that the case is worth, plaintiffs naturally think that the case is worth more than the defendants. It's not just that they're making that claim to convince the jury
所以一旦我们知道我们处于什么角色，我们在哪一边，我们的利益是什么，我们客观的能力就会在很大程度上消失。所以如果我们假设诉讼中有一名原告和一名被告，我们要求他们向我们透露他们认为案件价值多少，原告自然认为案件价值高于被告。这不仅仅是他们为了说服陪审团
or the judge, but they actually come to believe that. And similarly, lots of salespeople think that what they're selling is worth more than what the buyer thinks that they're buying. So you have this kind of bias to see the world in the way that would favor your side. So at one level, of course, when we want something very badly, it makes sense that we spend a lot of time thinking about what we want. Why does this make us less effective as negotiators? Because negotiation is not one person decision making.
或法官而提出的主张，而是他们实际上开始相信这一点。同样，许多销售人员认为他们卖的东西比买家认为他们买的东西更值钱。所以你有一种偏见，以有利于你这一方的方式看待世界。所以从一个层面来看，当然，当我们非常想要某样东西时，花很多时间思考我们想要什么是有道理的。为什么这会使我们作为谈判者效率降低？因为谈判不是一个人的决策。
If you were the dictator and you could make the decision, it wouldn't be a negotiation. The fact that you need to work with another person, or many other people, requires that you take their perspective to imagine what the world looks like from their side so that you aren't putting things on the table that they're never going to accept under any circumstance. One of the key limitations that we find in negotiation is that people don't do a good enough job of thinking about the decisions of the other party. So you say that when two parties are negotiating, overconfidence can form a major obstacle
如果你是独裁者，你可以做出决定，那就不叫谈判了。你需要与另一个人或许多人合作的事实，要求你站在他们的角度，想象从他们那边看世界是什么样子，这样你就不会把他们无论如何都不会接受的东西放在桌面上。我们在谈判中发现的一个关键局限是，人们在思考对方的决策方面做得不够好。所以你说当双方在谈判时，过度自信会形成达成协议的主要障碍。
to reaching an agreement. Is that connected to what you were just telling me about defendants and prosecutors in sort of courtroom settings? Absolutely. to reaching an agreement. Is that connected to what you were just telling me about defendants and prosecutors in sort of courtroom settings? Absolutely. So we see the world from our own perspective. We have a biased view of what a fair price would be.
这与你刚才告诉我的关于法庭环境中被告和检察官的情况有关吗？绝对有关。所以我们从自己的角度看世界。我们对什么是公平价格有偏见的看法。
And we're overconfident that if we simply hold out for our position, that the other side will eventually fold. And too many deals are missed because we have parties on both sides holding out for something that's tilted in their favor and not finding that viable price in the middle that both sides could in fact live with. So why in the world do we spend so much money on attorneys
而且我们过度自信，认为如果我们只是坚持我们的立场，对方最终会妥协。太多的交易因为双方都坚持对自己有利的东西，而没有找到双方实际上都能接受的中间可行价格而错失了。那么为什么我们还要花这么多钱请律师
to go through expensive court procedures to end up with a deal that we could have reached on our own without all those expenses. So anytime that we've incurred these expenses for the opportunity to have this fight with the other side, we're ending up with a deal that's worse than what we could have had had had the two parties used reasonable negotiation procedures and reached a deal more efficiently. Hmm. Many listeners might be listening to this and saying, you know, when I'm going in to have a difficult negotiation, whether that's buying a car or asking for a raise or, you know,
去经历昂贵的法庭程序，最终达成一个我们本可以在没有所有这些费用的情况下自己达成的协议呢？所以任何时候，当我们为了有机会与对方进行这场争斗而承担这些费用时，我们最终达成的协议都比双方使用合理的谈判程序并更有效地达成协议所能达到的结果要差。嗯。许多听众可能在听这个节目时会说，你知道，当我进入一场困难的谈判时，无论是买车还是要求加薪，或者，你知道，
discussing something that is unpleasant with a partner or a spouse, I often feel underconfident, not overconfident. Can underconfidence also undermine us and how do we strike a balance between overconfidence and underconfidence? It's a great question. So my excellent colleague at the Haas School at Berkeley, Don Moore, I think of as the world's expert on appropriate confidence. And he wrote a book called Perfectly Confident. What Don finds is that when people are in domains where they lack competence, they are even less confident than they should be.
与伴侣或配偶讨论一些不愉快的事情，我经常感到缺乏自信，而不是过度自信。缺乏自信也会破坏我们吗？我们如何在过度自信和缺乏自信之间取得平衡？这是一个很好的问题。我在伯克利哈斯商学院的优秀同事唐·摩尔，我认为他是适当自信方面的世界专家。他写了一本名为《完美自信》（Perfectly Confident）的书。唐发现，当人们处于缺乏能力的领域时，他们的自信心甚至比他们应该有的还要低。
But when people are in domains where they feel confident, they're even more confident than their skills and abilities should lead them to be. So given that that's the case, and given that sometimes we have to be negotiating in areas that might not be areas of competence, how do we solve this problem? So sometimes we don't need to.
但当人们处于他们感到自信的领域时，他们的自信心甚至比他们的技能和能力所应有的还要高。既然如此，而且考虑到有时我们必须在可能不是我们能力范围内的领域进行谈判，我们如何解决这个问题？所以有时我们不需要。
If you're in a flea market and you're buying a souvenir for $15 and you make a mistake, no big problem. And I would say, get on with life and don't worry about it. If it's an important part of your work setting and you don't have the expertise, perhaps you need to buy it or borrow it from someone else in your firm or from an outside advisor. So we need to understand when we know too little,
如果你在跳蚤市场买一个15美元的纪念品，你犯了一个错误，没关系。我会说，继续生活，别担心。如果这是你工作环境中重要的一部分，而你没有专业知识，也许你需要从公司里的其他人或外部顾问那里购买或借用。所以我们需要了解我们什么时候知道得太少，
and we need to make up for our lack of personal expertise by relying on the expertise of someone else who we can trust. I'd like you to talk about another bias that affects us when we're negotiating. This one is called anchoring. Can you explain what anchoring is? Sure. 50 years ago Kahneman and Tversky, well-known psychologists who created the field of behavioral economics in many ways, did an experiment where they basically asked people what percent of the countries in the United Nations were from Africa, and they said, wait, before you give me your estimate,
我们需要通过依赖我们可以信任的别人的专业知识来弥补我们个人专业知识的不足。我想请你谈谈另一个在谈判时影响我们的偏见。这个叫做“锚定”。你能解释一下什么是锚定吗？当然。50年前，卡尼曼和特沃斯基，在许多方面开创了行为经济学领域的著名心理学家，做了一个实验，他们基本上问人们联合国中来自非洲的国家占百分之几，他们说，等等，在你给我估计之前，
let's get an estimate from a roulette wheel. And the roulette wheel either stops at 65 or 10, and people are asked is the number higher or lower than 10 or 65. And people who see 65 say lower, and they reduce to 65 to 45 on average. The people who see 10 come all the way up to 24. And while both parties rejected these unreasonable anchors, you get a dramatic difference based on did I start high and come down or start low and come up. And the same is true in negotiations.
让我们从轮盘赌中得到一个估计。轮盘赌要么停在65，要么停在10，人们被问到这个数字是高于还是低于10或65。看到65的人说更低，他们平均将65降至45。看到10的人一直升到24。虽然双方都拒绝了这些不合理的锚点，但你根据我是从高处开始向下，还是从低处开始向上，得到了巨大的差异。在谈判中也是如此。
If you're selling, you're much better off starting with a high price and coming down to something viable but favorable to you within the zone of possible agreement. If you're buying just the opposite, better to start with a low number and come up into the zone of possible agreement. So as a negotiator, anchoring can be very, very effective. On the other hand, you wanna anchor with a number that's reasonable enough to get their attention. If they're not paying attention to you, then that's not very helpful.
如果你在卖东西，最好从高价开始，然后降到一个可行但对你在可能达成协议的范围内有利的价格。如果你在买东西，正好相反，最好从一个低数字开始，然后升到可能达成协议的范围内。所以作为谈判者，锚定可以非常非常有效。另一方面，你想要用一个足够合理以引起他们注意的数字来锚定。如果他们不注意你，那就不太有帮助了。
So if you look at a house for, that's on the market for $499,000, and you read anchors have a dramatic influence, you might offer them $100,000, but they're simply gonna ignore you. That's not gonna anchor the discussion. But it might be the case that if you've done your homework that you can anchor, you can respond with 460 rather than 470
所以如果你看一栋市场价为499,000美元的房子，你读到锚点有巨大的影响，你可能会给他们出价100,000美元，但他们只会忽略你。那不会锚定讨论。但如果你做了功课，你可能会锚定，你可以用460而不是470来回应
and anchor them at a lower number and that could could favor that could tilt you in a favorable direction in terms of what the ultimate price will be. So the general advice is to identify what is a viable range of agreements and then anchor near your preferred end of that zone. So let's get to listener questions now Max. This first one comes from a listener named Rose. I'm just wondering about what negotiation looks like in certain cultures and how much
并把他们锚定在一个更低的数字上，这可能对你有利，可能在最终价格方面向有利于你的方向倾斜。所以一般的建议是确定什么是可行的协议范围，然后锚定在你偏好的该区域末端附近。那么让我们来回答听众的问题吧，马克斯。第一个来自一位名叫罗斯的听众。我只是想知道在某些文化中谈判是什么样子的，以及这在多大程度上
that should play into it. So I'm from the Midwest where negotiation is kind of looked on pretty negatively. It's accepted for things like buying a car, but in general, if you were to haggle with someone, it's not considered the most socially acceptable thing. So I'm just wondering outside of the Midwest, if there's other places like this, how much that should come into our minds as we start to negotiate with people, or do I just need to get over my Nebraska niceness to get a better deal? So Max, there are clearly cultures in which haggling is more the norm than others. When you're living in a haggling,
应该发挥作用。我来自中西部，那里谈判被看得相当负面。买车之类的事情是可以接受的，但总的来说，如果你要和某人讨价还价，这被认为不是最社会可接受的事情。所以我只是想知道在中西部之外，还有没有其他这样的地方，当我们开始与人谈判时，这应该在多大程度上进入我们的脑海，还是我只需要克服我的内布拉斯加式的“客气”来获得更好的交易？所以马克斯，显然有些文化中讨价还价比其他文化更常见。当你生活在一个讨价还价
averse culture like Rose's, how should she proceed? Well, first of all, I love Rose's question, and I love the fact that after talking about cultures, she focuses on Nebraska. So a lot of other listeners, when they hear culture, they might have been thinking China or Japan. And I think Rose highlights that we have different cultures in different parts of the U.S. We have different cultures in different industries.
厌恶的文化中，比如罗斯的文化，她应该如何进行？好吧，首先，我喜欢罗斯的问题，我喜欢在谈论文化之后，她专注于内布拉斯加州的事实。所以很多其他听众，当他们听到文化时，他们可能想到的是中国或日本。我认为罗斯强调了我们在美国不同地区有不同的文化。我们在不同行业有不同的文化。
So it's important to understand the world that you're in. So my first advice to Rose is, sounds like life is fine in Nebraska for her, and she should be perfectly comfortable not negotiating in situations that don't call for negotiation. On the other hand, if she moves to a place where negotiation is the norm, she needs to adapt to that. Or if she takes a job and a career where the prices aren't fixed and haggling is normal, she needs to adapt to that.
所以了解你所处的世界很重要。所以我给罗斯的第一个建议是，听起来她在内布拉斯加州生活得很好，她应该完全可以放心地在不需要谈判的情况下不进行谈判。另一方面，如果她搬到一个谈判是常态的地方，她需要适应这一点。或者如果她从事了一份价格不固定且讨价还价很正常的工作和职业，她需要适应这一点。
And in my book, Negotiation and the Game has Changed, one of the points that I make is that we're now negotiating with more and more people who are different from ourselves, who come from different cultures, and we want to understand what the norms look like. Rose might also find it intriguing to know that I was in December, I was hiking up to Machu Picchu and the guide on the trip said, and by the way, in a lot of emerging economies, it's normal to haggle with people over price. He said, don't do that. People in Peru are used to offering you a fair price, and you should take it or leave it rather than to haggle. So turns out that Cusco and Machu Pichu may have a lot in common with Nebraska that wouldn't have been apparent on the surface. On the other hand, there are times when negotiating matters a whole lot. 30 years ago, Linda Babcock, excellent colleague at Carnegie Mellon, basically
在我的书《谈判：游戏规则已变》中，我提出的观点之一是，我们现在正在与越来越多与我们不同、来自不同文化的人进行谈判，我们想要了解规范是什么样的。罗斯可能还会觉得有趣的是，我在12月徒步前往马丘比丘，旅行中的导游说，顺便说一句，在许多新兴经济体中，就价格与人讨价还价是正常的。他说，别那样做。秘鲁人习惯于给你一个公平的价格，你应该接受它或离开它，而不是讨价还价。所以事实证明，库斯科和马丘比丘可能与内布拉斯加州有很多共同点，这在表面上是不明显的。另一方面，有些时候谈判非常重要。30年前，卡内基梅隆大学的优秀同事琳达·巴布科克基本上
found out that women were less likely to have a hagwool and as a result, they're starting salaries were too low and that that created enormous pay differences across their career. Laura Cray, now at Berkeley, suggests that that's no longer true. So we need to understand the culture and the time and the place and what's appropriate and take that into consideration as we develop our own strategy. This makes me think that when you're negotiating with someone, you might be negotiating over something you're actually exchanging.
发现女性不太可能讨价还价，结果她们的起薪太低，这在她们的职业生涯中造成了巨大的薪酬差异。现在在伯克利的劳拉·克雷认为，这已经不再是事实了。所以我们需要了解文化、时间和地点以及什么是适当的，并在我们制定自己的策略时将其考虑在内。这让我想到，当你与某人谈判时，你可能正在就你实际交换的东西进行谈判。
So you're selling me a car, I'm trying to buy a car. So at one level, the negotiation is about something that is tangible to something that's material. But as we're negotiating with each other, the act of negotiation itself carries psychological meaning. And so if I come in and I basically lowball you to an extent in terms of what you want for the car, you know, you're offering a used car for, you know, $6,000 and I offer you a hundred bucks, you know, you're not just going to see that as a
所以你在卖我一辆车，而我正试图买一辆车。在某种层面上，谈判是关于有形物质的交易。但当我们进行谈判时，谈判行为本身就带有心理意义。如果我一上来就给出一个极低的报价，比如你卖一辆二手车要6000美元，而我只出100美元，你不会仅仅把它看作是一个
low anchor. You might not even dismiss me. You might be offended by what it is that I'm doing. And it makes me realize that negotiations are not just about the thing being negotiated, they're also about how we see ourselves, our self-worth, how we believe the other person sees us. It's tied up with all of these psychological issues. Absolutely. So Shankar, let's assume that we're acquaintances, which we are, but we've never had dinner together. And so let's assume that I'm the one selling the car for 6,000. And I think, you know, I'm happy with 5,500. And since you're my acquaintance, you know,
低锚点。你甚至可能不会拒绝我，而是会因为我的行为感到被冒犯。这让我意识到，谈判不仅仅是关于谈判的对象，还关乎我们如何看待自己、我们的自我价值，以及我们认为对方如何看待我们。它与所有这些心理问题交织在一起。当然。那么，Shankar，假设我们是熟人，我们确实是，但我们从未一起吃过饭。假设我是那个以6000美元卖车的人。我想，你知道，5500美元我就很满意了。既然你是我的熟人，你知道，
I'd probably even be okay selling it to you for $5,000 and taking a little bit less than what I think the market could bear. But when you open with that $100 offer, or even a $3,000 offer, I think, wait a second, I was dealing with you as if our relationship matters. Your unreasonable offer suggests this is a very different world.
我甚至可能愿意以5000美元卖给你，比我认为的市场价稍微低一点。但当你以100美元，甚至3000美元的报价开场时，我会想，等一下，我本是把我们的关系放在心上才和你交易的。你那不合理的报价表明，这完全是另一回事了。
Right. So not only do we get a breakdown in the negotiation, but I don't like you as well because of the way you handled that particular situation. So we got another comment from a listener named Roxana, and Roxana heard the story you shared about getting sucked into a negotiation over a taxi while you and your wife were in Thailand. In the incident that you mentioned, two taxi drivers quoted you a charge that was higher than you wanted to pay, but the difference in both cases was less than a dollar.
没错。所以，不仅谈判破裂了，而且因为你处理那种特定情况的方式，我也不喜欢你了。我们收到了另一位听众Roxana的评论，她听了你分享的关于你在泰国和你妻子在出租车上陷入谈判的故事。在你提到的那次事件中，两名出租车司机向你报出的价格都高于你愿意支付的价格，但在两种情况下，差额都不到一美元。
Roxana shared her own story of witnessing an American tourist haggling over 25 cents when buying a handmade blouse from an indigenous woman in Mexico. And her point was that context matters. When people from wealthy countries visit less wealthy ones, there is a big economic power imbalance. Should we consider that when we're negotiating, Max? Absolutely. If you'll recall in the taxi story, I knew that my students were gonna quiz me the next day on what did I pay for the taxi. But my spouse in that story, who was standing on the street, not in the taxi because of my frugalsness, would very much be on Roxanna's side of that story. So I think that we should often consider
Roxana分享了她自己的故事，她目睹了一位美国游客在墨西哥向一位原住民妇女购买手工衬衫时，为了25美分讨价还价。她的观点是，背景很重要。当来自富裕国家的人访问较贫穷的国家时，存在巨大的经济权力失衡。Max，我们在谈判时应该考虑到这一点吗？当然。如果你还记得那个出租车的故事，我知道我的学生第二天会问我付了多少钱打车。但在那个故事中，因为我的节俭而站在街上、没能坐上出租车的我的妻子，会非常支持Roxana的观点。所以我认为我们应该经常考虑
the nature of the relationship, the nature of the transaction, how important the money is to us when we decide whether and how aggressively the money is to us when we decide whether and how aggressively we should negotiate. So despite the fact that I may be on the wrong side of Roxana's argument, I'm gonna side with her in terms of the general point she's making. Yeah, because I think sometimes,
关系的性质、交易的性质，以及当我们决定是否应该谈判以及应该多激进地谈判时，这笔钱对我们有多重要。所以，尽管我可能在Roxana的论点中处于错误的一方，但我会在她提出的总体观点上支持她。是的，因为我认为有时，
I think this happened to you in Thailand, you sort of get caught up in the moment in sort of the excitement of the negotiation, or even just a sense of fairness where you feel like you're being taken advantage of. And I think the point that she is making here, which is an important one, is that maybe sometimes it's okay to be taken advantage of. Yeah, or I would say reframe it as to there's better uses of your time than haggling with somebody over a small amount of money who needs some money more than you.
我想你在泰国时就发生了这种情况，你会被那一刻的谈判兴奋感所吸引，或者仅仅是一种公平感，让你觉得自己在被占便宜。我认为她在这里提出的观点很重要，那就是有时候被占便宜也没关系。是的，或者我会说，将其重新定义为：与其和一个比你更需要钱的人为了一小笔钱讨价还价，不如把时间花在更有意义的事情上。
than haggling with somebody over a small amount of money who needs some money more than you. Our guest is behavioral scientist Max Bezerman joining us to answer listener questions about his work on negotiation. More of those questions in a moment. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Your Questions Answered, our segment where we answer listeners' follow-up questions about ideas we've featured on the show. Today we're talking with Max Bezerman. He researches the dynamics of negotiation at the Harvard Business School.
与其和一个比你更需要钱的人为了一小笔钱讨价还价。我们的嘉宾是行为科学家Max Bezerman，他加入我们来回答听众关于他谈判研究的问题。稍后会有更多问题。你正在收听的是《Hidden Brain》。我是Shankar Vedantam。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是Shankar Vedantam。这是我们的“回答你的问题”环节，我们在这里回答听众关于节目中提到的观点的后续问题。今天我们与Max Bezerman交谈。他在哈佛商学院研究谈判动态。
Max, we got another question from a listener named Elizabeth. She's a divorce attorney and works with couples with years or decades of animosity between them. Elizabeth feels that such hostility can get in the way of reaching the best outcome. So she asks, what are some tips for negotiating in a low trust or zero trust relationship? What do you think, Max? So there's too much harm that occurs in The divorce process in too many cases and sometimes there are also children involved who suffer as a result of the animosity Between parties. Um, I think we should also think about the fact that
Max，我们收到了另一位听众Elizabeth的问题。她是一名离婚律师，与那些有着多年甚至几十年积怨的夫妇打交道。Elizabeth觉得这种敌意会阻碍达成最佳结果。所以她问，在低信任或零信任的关系中，有哪些谈判技巧？你觉得呢，Max？在太多的案例中，离婚过程中发生了太多的伤害，有时还涉及孩子，他们会因为双方之间的敌意而受苦。嗯，我认为我们也应该考虑到这样一个事实：
The longer the process goes on and the more legal Activity that occurs the more legal activity that occurs, the more expensive the process is to both parties. So one interesting issue is when you raise the temperature in the negotiation out of some sort of desire to harm the other party, how are they going to respond? And a quick answer is that they're likely to reciprocate. And all of a sudden, now we're not getting anything
过程持续的时间越长，法律活动越多，对双方来说过程就越昂贵。所以一个有趣的问题是，当你出于某种伤害对方的欲望而提高谈判的激烈程度时，他们会如何反应？简单的回答是，他们很可能会进行报复。突然之间，我们并没有从对对方的发泄中得到任何东西，
out of our venting toward the other party. We're simply increasing the emotional grief we suffer and we're increasing the costs that it's gonna take to resolve the dispute. But one role that mediators can play, mediators are simply people with negotiation skills who help two parties reach agreement. One of the nice parts about the use of a mediator
我们只是增加了我们所承受的情感痛苦，并增加了解决纠纷所需的成本。但调解人可以发挥一个作用，调解人只是拥有谈判技巧的人，他们帮助双方达成协议。使用调解人的好处之一是
is that they can bring down the temperature and bring reasonableness to both sides of the negotiation. So one viable answer to our divorce attorney is that when things get particularly tough, that may be a good time to bring in a skilled meat eater. Yeah, I mean, it's a tricky position, I think, for a lawyer to be, because the lawyer is committed, professionally committed, to serving
他们可以降低激烈程度，并为谈判双方带来理性。所以给我们的离婚律师的一个可行答案是，当事情变得特别棘手时，那可能是一个引入熟练调解人的好时机。是的，我的意思是，我认为这对律师来说是一个棘手的位置，因为律师在职业上致力于服务
her client's best interests, and that could often mean getting the client the best deal or getting the client the best outcome in the negotiation. you know the best outcome in the negotiation but I think partly what you're saying here is that both parties are not well served when they have two eager attorneys who are willing to go at it hammer and tongs instead of finding someone who can actually bridge the divide between the two. That's right so imagine that you have a divorcing couple and their family wealth is a half a million dollars, $500,000.
她客户的最佳利益，这通常意味着为客户争取最好的交易或在谈判中获得最好的结果。但我认为你在这里所说的一部分是，当双方有两个急于求成、愿意针锋相对而不是寻找能够真正弥合双方分歧的人的律师时，双方都无法得到很好的服务。没错，所以想象一下，你有一对正在离婚的夫妇，他们的家庭财富是50万美元。
And they could amicably reach a resolution and they could divide it at $250,000 each or maybe one side would get 200,000 and other side would get 300,000 for a variety of reasons that could be justified. But if instead we spend a year and a half fighting through the court system, and we're paying lawyers along the way and we incur $200,000 of legal expenses, now there's only $300,000 to divide in addition to the fact that we've hurt the emotional connection between the two parties, they could have all kinds of repercussions. If there were children involved, all that hostility is likely to have a negative effect on the children as well.
他们可以友好地达成决议，他们可以将其平分为每人25万美元，或者出于各种可以证明的理由，一方可能得到20万，另一方得到30万。但如果我们花了一年半的时间在法院系统中争斗，并且在此过程中支付律师费，我们产生了20万美元的法律费用，现在只剩下30万美元可以分配，此外，我们还伤害了双方之间的情感联系，这可能会产生各种连锁反应。如果涉及孩子，所有的敌意都可能对孩子产生负面影响。
So figuring out how to get to a wise agreement efficiently and getting over the emotional barriers can be critical to coming up with a wise agreement. Our next comment comes from a listener named Kathy. Kathy heard our interview with you, Max, and called in to share a positive negotiation experience that she had while buying a car. The year was about 1993 and I was a single mom on a shoestring budget with no experience in buying a car.
所以，弄清楚如何高效地达成明智的协议并克服情感障碍，对于达成明智的协议至关重要。我们的下一条评论来自一位名叫Kathy的听众。Kathy听了我们对你的采访，Max，并打来电话分享了她在买车时的一次积极的谈判经历。那是在1993年左右，我是一个预算紧张的单身母亲，没有任何买车经验。
I visited several car lots and was horrified at the transparent lies and aggressive sales tactics both about their competitors cars and their own cars. Disillusioned, I did some homework and decided to put the shoe on the other foot. I did a few test drives and realized that a Nissan Sentra was my best option. I researched dealer prices and reasonable markups, decided on my price, somewhere around $15,700 to $16,000 if I remember right, and began. I called the three Nissan dealers within 75 miles, confirmed that they had the car I wanted on site, and explained that I had the cash in hand or in the bank and was willing to
我参观了几个车行，对他们关于竞争对手汽车和他们自己汽车的透明谎言以及激进的销售策略感到震惊。失望之余，我做了一些功课，决定换位思考。我做了几次试驾，意识到日产Sentra是我最好的选择。我研究了经销商价格和合理的加价，确定了我的价格，如果我没记错的话，大约在15700到16000美元之间，然后开始了。我给75英里内的三家日产经销商打了电话，确认他们有我想要的车，并解释说我手头或银行里有现金，并且愿意
buy a car that day. They loved hearing that. Then I pitted the dealers against each other. And every time one guy gave me a cheaper price, I called the other two saying, well, can you beat this particular price? And it was impressive how quickly the prices came down. Then the last salesman said to me,
当天就买车。他们很喜欢听到这个。然后我让经销商们互相竞争。每当一个人给我一个更便宜的价格，我就打电话给另外两家说，好吧，你能打败这个价格吗？价格下降的速度之快令人印象深刻。然后最后一位推销员对我说，
I can do better for you. I get a commission on how many cars I sell regardless of price. I will sell you this car for $12,700 if you come in today. I was delighted. It was well below dealer price and I had other salesmen just be astonished at the price I got. So obviously Cathy did well well here, Max, but can you unpack for us what she did right? What can we learn from her story?
我可以为你做得更好。无论价格如何，我卖出的车越多，我的佣金就越多。如果你今天来，我就以12700美元的价格把这辆车卖给你。我很高兴。这远低于经销商价格，其他推销员对我的价格感到惊讶。显然Kathy在这里做得很好，Max，但你能为我们解析一下她做对了什么吗？我们能从她的故事中学到什么？
I love Kathy's story, and it's in a context that a lot of people describe as their least favorite negotiation. People don't like buying queries broadly. So I think that Kathy did two things that are just terrific. One, she did a lot of homework. And when my students take a semester course on negotiation, one of the things that they learn is that so much of negotiation occurs before you even talk to the other side. Doing your homework, learning what the dealer cost is, learning what the competitive landscape looks like is absolutely critical to negotiating effectively. So I think Cathy did a
我喜欢Kathy的故事，它发生在一个许多人描述为他们最不喜欢的谈判环境中。人们通常不喜欢买车。所以我认为Kathy做了两件非常棒的事情。第一，她做了大量的功课。当我的学生参加谈判学期课程时，他们学到的事情之一就是，大部分谈判在与对方交谈之前就已经发生了。做功课，了解经销商成本，了解竞争格局，对于有效谈判至关重要。所以我认为Kathy在做功课方面做得
great job at doing her homework. And then second, she did a great job at creating competition. And she was well aware that when she talked to dealer A, dealer B was a very attractive alternative that she had. And when she was talking to B, she knew that C was available. So by having multiple options, it gave Kathy power and comfort. And that allowed her to get a far better price than she would if she simply went into a single car dealer,
非常出色。第二，她在创造竞争方面做得很好。她很清楚，当她与经销商A交谈时，经销商B是她拥有的一个非常有吸引力的替代方案。当她与B交谈时，她知道C也是可用的。因此，拥有多个选择给了Kathy权力和舒适感。这使她能够获得比仅仅走进一家单一汽车经销商，
used her intuition and kind of winged it. So I give Cathy great marks on both preparation and creating a competitive environment that strengthened her power in negotiating for her desired car. I'm wondering, Max, as you have written this new book, you obviously are the author of many other books on negotiation as well. Are there patterns that you see that come up over and over again? Are there ideas that you would want to leave our listeners with to keep in mind as they go about their lives negotiating about things that are important to them? Absolutely.
凭直觉行事要好得多的价格。所以我给Kathy在准备工作和创造竞争环境方面打了高分，这增强了她在谈判自己想要的汽车时的权力。Max，我想知道，当你写这本新书时，你显然也是许多其他谈判书籍的作者。你是否看到了反复出现的模式？有没有什么想法是你希望留给我们的听众，让他们在处理生活中重要的事情进行谈判时记住的？当然。
So, first thing, people too often assume a mythical fixed pie. They assume that the surplus to be divided between the two parties is fixed and they miss opportunities to create joint gain. Second, there are two myopic. They focus on their perspective when there's so much advantage to thinking about the perspective of the other side,
首先，人们太容易假设一个神话般的固定蛋糕。他们假设双方之间要分配的剩余部分是固定的，从而错失了创造共同收益的机会。第二，他们太短视了。他们只关注自己的视角，而思考对方的视角却有很大的优势，
to empathize with the position of the other side so that you can understand who they are and how you can negotiate with them most effectively. And following a couple of the questions, to understand how important it is to understand the environment, perhaps culture, perhaps economic circumstances of the other side to figure out what the actual negotiation game looks like and how to best negotiate effectively in that environment. Max Bezerman is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. He's the author of Negotiation, The Game Has Changed. Max, thank you so much for joining us again on Hidden Brain.
去同情对方的立场，这样你就能了解他们是谁，以及如何最有效地与他们谈判。并且根据几个问题，了解理解环境的重要性，也许是文化，也许是对方的经济状况，以弄清楚实际的谈判游戏是什么样子的，以及如何在那种环境中最好地进行有效谈判。Max Bezerman是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。他是《谈判：游戏规则已改变》的作者。Max，非常感谢你再次加入我们的《Hidden Brain》。
Thank you. It's been a pleasure to be back with you again. ["The Game Has Changed"] Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains' executive editor. If you enjoy the ideas we explore on the show, be sure to check out our weekly newsletter.
谢谢。很高兴能再次回到这里。[“游戏规则已改变”] 《Hidden Brain》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quarell、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes、Andrew Chadwick和Nick Woodbury。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢我们在节目中探讨的观点，请务必查看我们的每周通讯。
We bring you new and interesting research about human behavior and every issue. And we always include a brain teaser and a moment of joy. You can read our newsletter and subscribe at news.hiddenbrain.org. That's N-E-W-S dot hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们每期都会为你带来关于人类行为的新的、有趣的发现。我们总是包含一个脑筋急转弯和一个快乐时刻。你可以在news.hiddenbrain.org阅读我们的通讯并订阅。那是N-E-W-S点hiddenbrain点org。我是Shankar Vedantam。很快再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。